is that you're not engaged in defensive
doxing. You're throwing [__] at the wall
and seeing what sticks.
>> Me?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I've only doxed people that are
unhinged and obsessed about me. I'm
pretty sure every person I've done has
been one of those people.
>> Have you done it or have you gotten gay
ops people in DG or gay ops people in
different discords to do it?
>> You lie and and defame people and you
lie and harass people. Like, you can't
stop lying. Let's not forget he fully
confessed to non-consensually sending
Pixie's tapes to this 17-year-old. He
totally confessed to Straight Raid that
he did it non-consensually. And he just
lies and says, "No, no, no. That's not
what I meant. I just meant like I was,
you know, I was sad it leaked. That's
all I meant, guys." He just lies. Oh,
combination of both. But if somebody
passes out to me, I'll post it. I don't
give a men. I'm looking for Dubbie.
Careful. Um,
[Music]
how are you, Stevie? This is uh,
apparently they're doing something from
the Anything else studio. Let's take a
look. I'm going to, by the way, I'm
going to take full I'm going to take
full credit for this. Okay, I'm going to
take full credit. Oh, whoops. I'm take
full credit for this with my Hi, I'm
Connor and I approve this message. All
right, we get full credit for this.
Whatever's happening here. Okay.
Whatever happens,
>> just no matter how this goes, I just
don't think it will actually turn to any
like conflict. Okay. I just don't think
it can. Um any conflict would be like
kind of performative and not really
matter. But maybe maybe I'm wrong. I'm I
if I would love to be wrong, okay, cuz I
I used to think Connor was like a pretty
good person deep down and I just I've
kind of been losing little pieces of
that along the way.
>> I'm chilling.
>> All right. Well, the past two weeks have
been a little crazy, wouldn't you say?
>> They sure,
>> dude. What? This is real, not AI. No,
this is very real. This is very real.
>> Have been Connor.
>> Excellent. So, one of the things that
was brought to my attention recently by
some drama folks uh was that I think
around two years ago, I took issue with
the streamer Chudlo Logic. And the
reason why I took issue with him was
because Queean
>> Oh, hold on. speaking with and in my
opinion normalizing
another streamer named food shops who is
an unrepentant lollycon.
>> It's been brought to my attention that
you have been raiding food shops
recently.
>> And by locon we mean lollycon enjoyer.
>> Yes. They enjoy that content.
>> Okay. It's kind of uh con means enjoyer.
Loi is the word and con means enjoyer.
Lolly con.
>> It is super.
>> This guy doesn't even watch anime.
>> You're weird. So, I guess my question is
why?
>> Oh, no. Probably because it reminds them
of little anime children or something.
>> My question is why are you rating them?
>> Because they're my strongest soldier.
>> Okay.
In what war?
>> In the war against evil.
>> And what And what is this definitional
evil?
>> The leftist and the tankies.
>> She's fighting the leftist and the
tankies right now.
>> We're fighting Queen Majestical. Yes.
>> I thought Okay. But I thought we've Oh,
we occupy so much space in this guy's
mind. Dude, the best part is I just keep
restating my opinion on that whole
chorus thing and it's like nothing to
do. I like literally don't have any
super far lefty opinions on it at all.
It's the same opinion I had on PV.
You're a tanky now. I guess so. I just
love We're fighting the tankies and the
communists by resisting Quean and Jto.
Okay. Cream and justical were like drama
frog a log commentary people not
necessarily like super politically
minded.
>> Yeah, but they're hanging on my nuts
until my court case is done.
>> Okay. But so by what dragging down the
the world's number one liberal streamer,
they're actually serving the interests
of leftists.
>> I guess they kind of are. That's like a
byproduct. They just don't like me.
>> Okay. So food shops is the number one
liberal warrior right now.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Well, I I I feel
>> Martin Luther King cheated on his wife
with a 17-y old white girl. Okay. So,
>> and Destiny, of course, is just like
Martin Luther King. Okay. He's basically
Martin Luther King. All right. Listen,
would you have stopped if M Destiny be
like, would you have stopped Martin
Luther King and the entire civil rights
movement just because you found out that
Martin Luther King was keeping child on
his uh hard drives? Really? Really? You
would have stopped all of civil rights
just because of a little child, Connor?
Really, Connor?
>> Oh, I don't know if that's true or not.
>> I don't I don't know if that's true or
not. I'm sorry.
>> Okay.
So besides maligning the the memory of
the dead Martin Luther King, which is
fine,
>> the Okay, so so my beef is that this was
my beef with Queen effectively a
logging, watching her content all the
time, her getting normalized in the
space, and then it seemed like Tread
Logic didn't have an instantaneous
revulsion to uh the un the lack of
apology or excuse me, the apology for
Lcon. My beef with Lollcon is that it's
>> I've I've always said this, King of
Sorro, that like listen, they're going
to they're going to release the dogs on
us, okay? They're going to threaten us.
They're going to try to beat us down,
but we will remain civil, okay? We will
win through civility. We will do it.
>> As far as I know, it's drawn
images of underage people.
Yeah. And so
>> we usually call those children. Yeah.
>> Children. Um, and so yeah, I find that
repulsive and I don't think that should
be normalized. And I think the reason
why it shouldn't be normalized is
because you're reinforcing a connection
within your own brain that is
effectively like some people use this
defense of like, oh, it's just a
drawing. It's just a drawing. But for
me, it's like it's not about the
drawing. It's about what it's doing to
you, the consumer. Now, here's the
here's the real question. Will Destiny
employ the exact argumentation food
shops did to defend Loi against Connor?
Because that would be that would be
cinema. Okay, that that argument if you
don't remember was Oh, are you saying
that like if you play GTA then you're
going to go do a mass? That was the
argument food shops did. Will is it
possible that Destiny would just
actually do it bar for bar? I don't
know. Okay.
>> I hope not.
>> Okay.
>> There's two conversations.
>> One is debate about lollycon and two is
a debate about whether or not I should
rate into food shops.
>> Can we
>> Which one do you want to start with?
>> Can we start with lollycon, please?
>> What's your favorite? I'm just kidding.
I'm kind of indifferent towards it.
Basically, I think that for most things,
you have to start kind of neutral and
then you figure out if something is good
or bad from there. Like if somebody says
like drinking soda, like I don't have an
opinion or consuming, you know, Marvel
movies and then you go from there. Um,
when it comes to lollycon stuff, I guess
the biggest concern is are you
normalizing like underage attraction
such that people are going to start
acting on it or performing it more in
the world or something like that. My
understanding is that doesn't happen.
Like if it did, if that was like ever
demonstrated, I'd probably feel
significantly different about it. I
don't even know how you would
demonstrate that. Um, but that would be
my thing. I would just put it in the
kink area like all the other kind of bad
things that people roleplay like u like
consent not consent.
>> How are you Stevie?
>> Hold on.
>> So, so lollycon is like CNC. Okay, hold
on.
>> Underage attraction such that people are
going to start acting on it or
performing it more in the world or
something like that.
>> My understanding is that doesn't happen.
Like if it did if that was like ever
demonstrated, I'd probably feel
significantly different about it. I
don't even know how you would
demonstrate that. Um, but that would be
my thing. I would just put it in the
kink area like all the other kind of bad
things that people role play like u like
this is uh this is bordering on the
ethical argument right that child
wouldn't be bad if it like if it if it
satiated some desire right this is the
argument Destiny's made for like a long
time if it satiated some desire reduced
that it it's like yeah pedal roleplay
okay all right we'll see cuz I'm sure
these arguments have been made to Connor
I wonder how Connor feels
I wonder how Connor feels about these
arguments.
>> Uh, no, but the lore for the Imperium is
that they're a xenocidal faction and
they will wipe out men, women, and
children of rival species.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> Okay. Um, okay. So, summarizing, um, I
don't care about the thing in and of
itself. I think if the thing manifests
as as more things or if other stuff
comes from it, I think that would be
concerning and I'd probably heavily at
least socially discourage it, if not
more. Yeah. But that's basically where
I'm at. Yeah.
>> Okay. than summarizing my perspective.
I'm worried that you uh and by the way
like Queen acts like oh oh Conor
Connor's hanging out with Stephen. He's
still talking to Stephen. Um you know
but but he holds this contradictory view
in reference to this uh topic. Quean spa
espouses the same view. I've heard him
say it like plenty of times. It's just
drawings ninja and he'll use the end
obviously.
>> Jesus the
>> Yeah. And you went and weren't you
accusing him of normalizing food shops
and you like had a whole problem with it
>> sometimes.
>> Jesus.
>> Yeah. It's awesome. But anyways, the
point
>> the point is that
um the point is that like number one, on
an individual level, I don't think you
should entertain that. Number two, I
don't think you should entertain it with
uh with your friends. Number three, if
you bump into friends who are
entertaining that part of their brain,
you should push them away for it. Number
four, I think that if it hits a certain
level of disgusting, it should be uh pro
prohibited eventually. And and I think
that for me um I could articulate lines
of prohibition that I would follow
through with if I was allowed to.
>> Okay, it's fair.
>> Okay, so that's that conversation and I
feel like we dealt with that head on
even if it's uncomfortable. So putting
that to the side.
>> Oh, thank God.
>> In my opinion, you're too permissive,
but I have a different opinion on it.
The next thing is using food shop.
>> By the way, we gained nothing from that
conversation. They both stated the same
opinion. They've stated like at least a
half dozen times before, right? They
both have the exact same positions.
There's no way you couldn't have just
figured this out by listening to either
of them talk for like 15 minutes on the
their thoughts on the topic. There's
nothing achieved by that conversation,
okay, at all. Except one thing. We get
to watch Destiny just totally humiliate
Connor, not take him seriously for like
how long was that? Was uh about 30
minutes of just Connor humiliation. We
had to watch. So, in terms of content,
the Connor humiliation is kind of worth
it to me on its own. you know,
>> as a weapon to fight Jtock in Queenman.
So, I think that this is
>> um a silly use of your time, energy, and
talent that the conflict doesn't
necessarily call for. Um, and that that
yeah, I would never use like a flawed
tool to attack my enemies. So I guess my
issue is um over the past year and a
half there's been obviously I mean
you've seen it because you're you're a
part of it um or you get impacted by it
is there's like a highly coordinated
network of degenerate creepy losers/
pedoph
>> highly coordinated losers
>> insurance company owners um like doobie
queen
>> the only person who collects child is
this fellow this is the only one this is
the only one who holds on to child
>> all these other people who are
>> I didn't say That doobie. He said that.
>> Um he said that
>> who are like con
>> subtle docs. Yeah, he's been menacing
Doobie with apparently apparently Dubbie
does insurance somehow
>> instantly.
>> No, that's like the quintuple down. He's
done it like multiple times. He did it
on food shops multiple times. Krueger,
he's done it multiple times since. So
everybody who was a little concerned
about it just he's just making it
obvious. Yeah, I would do that. Yeah, I
am threatening that
>> like working. I used to call it with in
reference to a woman whose name will
never be
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure. Yes. A year and a
half. Yeah, Destiny can't tell time when
he's being hyperbolic, right? So, the
Pixie stuff started as of 7 months ago.
Okay, basically 7 months ago, and now
it's a year and a half. He's more than
doubling the time
working. I used to call it with in
reference to a woman whose name will
never be bismerched here again. Kelly
Jean. Um, I used to use this phrase
reputation workshopping where they would
go into Discords and they would
constantly um just like do that like
work on people's reputations and make
every make sure everybody like feels the
same way about things
>> to damage or to reinforce
>> both. It can be to reward. So he can
show evidence of this. Yes. other than
vibes, but because I think his evidence
of this is people don't like me and
that's because of these because of a
coordinated cabal to like make sure
people don't like me. But it's like,
dude, people just don't like you. People
don't like people who kids repeatedly.
People don't like people who hold on to
child after being informed that the the
object of the is a minor. People don't
like that. People just generally don't
like this behavior. People don't like uh
consent violation. You are a master of
sex consent violation. People don't like
this and they're capable of expressing
that dislike and not liking you totally
on their own without me or queen to
guide their way. What they see as loyal
or good behavior or it can be to damage
or attack what they see as people
outgroup people basically.
>> Why should we care about their opinions
at all?
>> So in the past you wouldn't care about
their opinions because you just don't
give them
>> decent drama content. But I'm saying
like, yeah, you're answering the
question. But
>> yeah, you wouldn't you just ignore them
until they kind of extinguish themselves
>> or get bored and move on to a new
target.
>> Yeah, I think the but
>> which again
I essentially did. I just I had moved
on, right? Like I had not entirely moved
on, but I had I had gone to like I
basically knew docs would drop and I'd
read the Destiny stuff then. We had a
whole bunch of other drama we were
doing. He decided to start picking
fights with the Discord. I ignored it
for a while. He was just picking fights
with the Discord. It was [__] weird,
right? He's been consistently escalating
with everybody he thinks is an op. But
the reason why they get bored is because
typically people like that. So like for
Kiwi Farms, for instance, like so my
main obsessive guy is Blav, right? He's
the guy, my alter ego who loves me.
>> Blav with a B.
>> Yeah. Who? Yeah. And any if I ever
reference him in any way, he's always
somehow it's like a victory or he thinks
it's like, oh my god, I live in this
guy. But so this is like
>> he does live in he does live in here.
you Destiny it Destiny is his head is
occupied so thoroughly by this guy,
okay, that Destiny decided to post
additional PII of the minor he was
program college full facial pictures,
right? Just to try to mess with this
guy, just to say that this guy's like on
disability or something and this guy's a
total loser. That's how much this guy's
in Destiny's head. Okay, like a person
who when if I reference them, that's the
only thing that they have to live for.
They get that, right? But the issue now,
this guy actually punched himself in the
face so hard he gave away the fact that
he was retaining child that he did a
minor, right? He did that all at the
this BL guy and he goes and this Blav
guy, he's the only thing he lives for is
like is me referencing him. You have
engaged, encouraged, and like fostered
this relationship from moment one. I I
don't know how you can look at this guy
and consider him anything but you. you
guys like like he is at least at your
level and you lost like you lost. You
are the guy who docks the minor you were
to this this dude so he could prove it
and you're like a laughing stock now.
How could you possibly rewrite this is
that guy's the loser.
>> I don't know why this happens. Maybe it
does in right leaning spaces. I don't
think but for some reason on the left
maybe it's not even the left. It's just
which is by the way unfortunat
seems like a pretty bad guy in that
docks people who are members of my
community. That's pretty. That's
obviously bad. We obviously disavow. We
hate that. Why Destiny would hand this
guy a massive win is beyond me, beyond
my understand.
>> For some reason, the network of leftist
socialist comm content creators started
to funnel a lot of this weird snarky
stuff and it's it's propagated up to the
highest levels of content. Oh, I think
this is a weird projection again, right?
Because this is what Destiny tried to do
when he supported my channel in the
beginning, right? Supported my channel
and then a bunch of people who were in
his community and hated Hassan would
just feed me like clips of Hassan,
right? I could just do infinite Hassan
content to like a thousand viewers and
make a money. Why? He's describing
something that literally was he
supported via my channel before he'd
gone to anyone else. If you want to call
it start content, I call it drama
content. I didn't go crazy on Hassan.
I'd never dox anybody around Hassan,
right? But like he literally tried to do
this. He describes it in his when he
does his whole skits mind map. He talks
about how like I used to have tools for
dealing with this and now I don't have
tools for dealing with this anymore.
Right. Yes. Yes. He's explained it
multiple times. Frugals. Yes. Right.
Such that that guy Blab who only used to
get attention from if I would give him
attention is the only thing she's
getting like 2 years ago now Hassan is
reading his posts about me on his
stream.
>> Who read the post first? Who mentioned
him first? We all put that. We all had
that as off limits until Destiny started
referencing this guy regularly.
Destiny started referencing this guy
regularly and then we're like, I guess I
guess that's like rules the game now. I
guess we can just do that, right? Jacob,
if I'm not mistaken, didn't he bring
this up when he was like trying to on
Zoe when he was on a Darius stream?
Didn't he bring this name up? I feel
like he's brought this name up so many
times and a bunch of us were like, well,
we don't want to reference anything in
the thread. And like at this point it's
like oh well I guess if he's going to
put it out there if he's gonna read
pages from his thread. None of the rest
of us do that. We really don't. I guess
Hassan started way at the end but I just
I don't understand how he can like not
take into account his own behavior when
he says these things.
>> Isn't that because he's using but Hassan
is using Blav as a weapon against you?
>> Correct.
>> Okay.
>> So that means that now it how how does
Connor take this victim narrative
seriously?
How does How is this that he he could
possibly take this seriously? Destiny's
the person who engaged with this guy,
who went back and forth with this guy,
who tried to amp this guy up as much as
he could, right? Destiny is the person
who did this for months, for years, went
back and forth with this guy. And then
and then somehow Desi just tells Connor,
"Well, now son's weaponizing this guy
against me, brother. You weaponized him
against yourself. It's not just up to
the person to ignore the anti-fan to
extinguish anything. Now, everybody on
that anti-fan side will go to these
places to get ammunition and then use it
against you. Now, even at that level, I
technically I don't give a because it is
what it is. But the problem, the thing
that um August tuned me into this while
ago, the thing that I have to consider
is that my fans, they they see those
attacks everywhere. And if I don't
respond or say anything or give any kind
of like messaging or anything, then it's
basically just like, oh, well, is that
true? Is like cuz Jesse hasn't addressed
this or what's going on here? So, but I
don't want to address it head on because
I don't want my stream, like I said, I
haven't had an interest in this content
for years. I don't want my whole
>> I haven't had an interest, guys. I
haven't had an interest in this content
for years.
For years.
Okay. How can he say this? Seriously,
bro, you've had how many albums of
screenshots of Discord messages that
don't even include me have you gone
through in the past 4 months? I haven't
engaged in this kind of content in
years. He can just sit here and like
transparently lie. It's It's crazy that
he can do this and just Well, I sorry
it's not crazy here. It's obvious
Conor's the only one watching and nobody
will call him out on it. But it's just
like it's weird. It's sad. It's goofy.
>> To be like, "Well, here's what Jessica
and all these people said about me
today. So, we're going to talk about
blah blah blah blah blah." Right. So,
then
>> he didn't when I wasn't talking about
him, he decided that he had to go get
screenshots from my discord of people
talking about him. I like talk to
somebody like food shops or if I pop in
every now and then or if I just like
chat with this person then this is a
person who can like talk and then other
people like kind of orbit them and like
chat and at least like in the discords
and everything when you've got the
weirdo creep like uh Duby and all these
other guys running around and trying to
like talk [__] and say weird [__] now
they're at least people dude they're not
talking saying weird they're relaying
factual information about you that you
basically lie to people and say is
unproven or unknown or just a rumor
Right. These guys will go, "No, no, no,
no. That's a lie. That's just Destiny
lying. He's just making things up."
Right? That's it. Who understand? Oh,
well, this is what's true. This is what
we can argue about fight. Yeah.
>> The the right-wing I just want to
clarify something that I think that I've
observed though is with the right-wing
there are their version of snarkers in
my opinion.
>> Yeah. But everybody hate like Milo.
Everybody hates Milo
>> or uh Kino Casino as an example.
>> I wouldn't even say them rightwing are
they? These are just like crazy people.
I don't think
>> Worski is not rightwing.
>> I feel like they hang out with
right-wingers, right? Doesn't didn't
Warskey used to hang out with
>> Yeah,
>> I don't know if I would consider those
guys right even wors rightwing.
>> Oh, he maybe he just doesn't know that
Warski is on Kino Casino.
>> I don't think so. They're not like
>> Oh, Ethan Ralph's also not rightwing.
Okay. Yeah, I would say so.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah.
>> Uh well, all right. So, if I understood
them to be right-wing, I think it's just
because I've heard them using it, the fs
slur,
>> etc., etc. Uh, but the what I would say
is that like those snarker uh
communities or those critic communities
or those ALOG communities or whatever,
they seem to be like they seem to just
like make content and then like move on.
Move on. You know what I'm saying? Where
they'll cover the drama of the day and
then they'll move on.
>> Sure. whereas um I don't think that I've
seen them get wrapped up with a single
character that they wanted to mean to
death.
>> Yeah. Uh this is just totally wrong.
Okay. Look at what happened with Rakita.
Are we going to argue that people didn't
do this with Rakita and take every tiny
tidbit that ever came out about Rakita
and just drive that [__] to the ground?
By the way, Rakita not directly fighting
back against these people ever. Destiny,
any tiny thing that comes out about me
or anyone I'm around, Destiny
immediately covers that. I like this is
not the same thing. There is like an
equal like back and forth that goes on
with uh with Destiny that I don't think
it was existing in in those other snark
communities either. Yes, he did. Okay.
Oh, you know what? Rakita did go back
and forth with like his KF thread now
that I think about it. Uh Anaubs.
Yeah, I feel like there's a bunch of
these examples. Yeah, but there's two
things going on there. one, if you're
getting referenced by those types of
people, you just wouldn't respond to
them. So, they would they wouldn't
respond to you and then it would just
move on. But two, those guys aren't
getting amplified by anybody. Like,
imagine if the Kino Casino did a show
and then Charlie Kirk was like quote
tweeting it. Yes, those guys would hit
that topic way more cuz
>> he was Was Destiny not like actually
saying that Queen and I should be Was he
not saying that before Hassan had ever
come close to this? Like beyond just the
initial like outcry? I could have sworn
that Desi was talking about us, getting
us way before there was ever the other
elements of this conspiracy going on.
>> Now they know that they're getting a
huge stream of rewards for it,
>> right? He was talking about doxing us.
He's talking about trying to get us
killed way before this other element of
the conspiracy comes in that he now
attaches.
>> So now like
>> I don't think there's an amplification
on the right now.
>> No, I don't think there Well, I just
they just don't do that kind of content
for whatever reason. I don't know why.
>> Yeah. Well, this is also only ever done
to like enforce this isn't like a even
though it's like a certain political
groupish that's doing it. It's it's all
like social behavior. Um it's not really
political like just to go a 180 on every
political position if it means opposing
me. Like he was defending Taylor Lorent
yesterday and he's defending Taylor Ren
today. That's crazy. But it's just
because it's to like attack me, you
know? Dude, this is actually, now that I
think about this, this is actually just
taking the concept of lull cows and
pretending that that doesn't exist. The
concept of a lowc is that you are going
to run that [__] into the ground, right?
That's like exactly what a loca is. And
Destiny is a local. Yes, Destiny is a
massive lowc like there is no more you
do not get more peak loc than doxing the
minor you so everybody can laugh at you
for holding out a child. Okay, that
doesn't get any any pe there's no other
there's no higher peak for loadm than
that. That is it. That is the peak. So I
don't know if I would even strictly call
it political. It just happened to
manifest in all these like left-leaning
political spaces.
>> Well, okay. So So just to we we already
articulated the lolli perspective
differences between our perspectives.
Then we also articulated like the I I
would never use food shops. Mhm.
>> Um the part of the reason why though
what what I'm afraid of um and this is
what I articulated to Chud is that um I
feel like by normalizing her by raiding
her by granting her some level of
success within the
>> let's also let's just say like me
chatting with food shops cuz using it's
not like I've got this
>> but you showed up on chat you you know
rated her and and by the way u you know
this is the only compliment that I will
give food chops is uh she had like she
stayed she got raided or whatever and I
think she was at like 700 or 800. She
maintained her number because she was
being she was talking about JTO she was
talking about Gleman
>> and then as a result the drama content
was good enough that she didn't drop
like a rock.
>> Sure.
>> She kept those people. But my my problem
or my fear is that uh you know she did
it as a joke and I understand it's a
joke.
>> She does the uh what do you call it?
Unless I've missed some like really
funny food shops moments, it's just that
she's doing the propaganda they want,
right? There's just an there is a there
is a like need for somebody to feed them
the idea that Destiny isn't like a
totally immoral piece of food shops is
the only one the the the avowed lollycon
small P is the only person who's willing
to take that up. Tom Fuller is not
willing to take that up, right? He's not
willing to take that up anymore. There
is nobody else. But there's an appetite
for anybody who will help them cope.
So yes, yes, they will stay there. The
the most degenerate cultists will stay
there. Absolutely.
>> But the tweet was like, "Oh, now that I
have some level of viewership, I'm going
to start trying to normalize my ideas in
reference to, you know, lollycon or
whatever." And so for me, I think that
there's probably a few lost souls in
there.
>> There might be
>> who your permissive attitude and they're
going to hear her apologia
>> on the other side of that coin. Uh,
okay. when I when I just cover the
chorus stuff. Is that the other side of
the coin? I don't think it is. That's
been most of my content the past two
days.
>> Men's apologia and then they're just
going to be like, "Yeah,
>> I don't care anywhere near enough about
the LA issue to give a about that." I
think if I had a stronger position on
it, like if I found out that they were
like kids or whatever, then I would be
like, "Okay, this is probably not a
person I want to be with." But I just
don't care about that issue.
>> Yeah. And it's not like there's any
other
>> If there are other people, I guess, that
I can chat with, then maybe. Not yet.
Not yet.
>> Um, it's a that's a rough world. You
know, you've experienced
lost souls. So, why would we allow
people to fall into that?
>> I don't think I don't think Connor
considers, by the way, Destiny keeps
saying, "Connor, you know, you've
experienced this harassment." I don't
think Connor sees this as harassment. I
think Connor just sees this like the way
things are online and he's like kind of
fine with it. He might not like some of
the stuff I say at this point, but
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Destiny never
apologizes for the smell. He just sits
there being a stinker.
>> Thank you very much for the three.
Appreciate you, buddy.
>> A trap.
>> No, I mean that like it's a rough world
in terms of like um the weird Discord
people that like those communities are
just like very very very active. Um like
>> and they're cannibalistic.
>> Yeah. Like I love him to death, but
Pisco will be 100% bought into those
communities in 6 months. Like guaranteed
he will be
>> what into the hate communities.
>> Absolutely 100%. cuz Aaron is fully one
trillion% bought in and all those people
are constantly in peace go's chat and in
his discords and everything else.
>> Uh I've just shown like dude all I have
to show is like the you say to like
anyone like I I don't know I don't have
to convince anybody but when I do when
somebody comes to me okay somebody says
like I think you're like way out to
lunch on this. All I have to do is go
show your like kick logs of you like
trying to taunt one of your victims,
your non-consensual recording, right?
That's all I have to show someone and
they're immediately like, "Oh, this guy
is actually a total piece of shit."
You're actually right. All I have to
show is you talking [__] about the silly
serious, right? And how that's changed
Pisco's views. That's all I would have
to show. Now, Pisco doesn't talk to me
except today on Twitter. Oh my god. But
Pisco doesn't really talk to me. We have
no DMs or anything, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, one day, one day I'll
rebuild the Pisco Bridge. Okay, one day.
So,
>> okay. I have I have higher faith for
Pisco because I'm hoping that his
rooting in the legal world and his
rooting, and by the way, in his content,
as at least as far as I've seen with the
the titling that he's done over the past
week, he's almost ignored the Ethan
Klein versus U drama, he's almost
exclusively been talking about like
mainstream news events.
>> Okay. I hope I'm wrong. We'll Well, I
hope I'm right, but um yeah, like you're
right, too.
>> Well,
>> Pisco doesn't want to do drama content.
He's never wanted to do drama content.
When has Pisco ever done drama content?
I don't see him doing that. I see him
doing entirely political content all the
time.
>> It's just it's a lot of pressure.
There's a lot.
>> Well, it is a lot of pressure. It's you
know when you have half a dozen to a
dozen people coming in and being like
disavow disavow you're a [__] piece
of
>> this isn't but this isn't like this is
Fitz's wheelhouse, right? Teeny tiny
Tony. like he is a sorry I shouldn't say
just political he's also like trying to
do law tube stuff like he talks to a lot
of the law tubers that was big law tube
content right but I don't think he just
does drama he's not just doing people
talking each other and I think the
basically the only way I saw him engage
with the H3 stuff was via the lawsuit
excuse me hanging out with this person
he's hanging out with that person yeah
it's a lot of pressure um but the but I
could see why a tactic that some people
will use is they're just going going to
focus on dry politics because they're
going to starve the drama frogs in their
community. Although, weirdly enough,
sorry to bring you up, Hutch, but Hutch.
Um, I see Hutch constantly getting
attacked and I don't think he's really
done much of the drama at all. I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong, but I
>> see somebody who
>> Hutch is just a really imprecise guy and
Hutch Hutch is like a That's a really
nice way of saying Hutch is just like a
who says things and then people attack
the things he says.
I'm sorry. Like Hutch is kind of just
loads a lot of the screenshots in the
communities and I think Egyptical talked
about it on a stream. Um Hutch made some
comment uh it was when I was in DC I
listened where he said something like oh
like Destiny can be rehabilitated in 5
years or something. I heard I got really
nerv what the do you even know like it's
just that felt so
>> I did cover it from a positive point of
view. I literally was totally charitable
to Hutch in that case
>> and then I think I said something on
stream maybe I said it to you down here
but I think I said something on stream
was like that was just a I don't know
whatever. Um, but then afterwards, I
think Hutch on his stream said something
like, "Oh, like I wasn't thinking too
much when I said that or whatever." When
he made that comment, uh, Joistical
Quean and then, uh, I don't think Spicy
Chat did, but Kiwi Farms tuned into
Hutch and then a lot of them shifted on
that because they're like, "We need a
full disaval from Hutch." Although
that's receded a bit because now they're
focused on you and lately Wick um, in
order to try to like tell you guys
you're never allowed to talk to me and
then and now Hutch is just fighting like
the kind of mainstream lefty political.
I was about to say we we that's actually
probably fairly easy transition is the
Taylor Lauren story, but I don't think
we're there yet.
>> Sure.
>> Um the I hear what you're saying.
>> Mhm. Hutch gets a lot of like main um
not main he gets a lot of like actual
political fighting. It's not just like
this weird alt community that's like
kind of hanging off me. Yeah.
>> Well,
>> they they focus on for a little bit but
not too much. Yeah.
>> So, if I if I could though, if I could
snap my fingers,
>> he watches you so much. Uh, there's a
big incentive to watch my stuff and
figure out how to argue that like I am
the things that Destiny has said. I
guess there's like a big incentive for
this. I don't know. It's just it's
bizarre.
>> Just like this weird alt community
that's like kind of hanging off me.
Yeah.
>> Well,
>> they they focus on for a little bit but
not too much. Yeah. So, if I if I could
though, if I could snap my fingers and I
could uh resolve the Pixie situation,
resolve the JSTO Sherry situation,
resolve the um all these situations. If
I could resolve all this stuff, I would.
And then I would be trying to focus on
like I I hate to say it, people are
going to make fun of me for it, but
that's okay. I'd be trying to focus on
like what PV was trying to do, which was
effectively taking the energy of Twitch
and YouTube politics, carving off 2 to
5% of it for canvasing operations, phone
calls, and volunteer organizations. I
wanted to do disaster relief, but that's
not uh nobody's really interested in
that yet.
>> Sure.
>> But the whole point of it is like at the
end of the day, Twitch and YouTube
politics is a bunch of nerds who there's
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars in Twitch and YouTube's YouTube
politics. There's hundreds of thousands
of people. Um the canvasing operations
were the one thing that seemed to
actually be like positive and real as a
result of this besides charities I
guess.
>> Yeah, I agree.
>> Um so that should be the job.
>> I agree 100 trillion%. Yeah.
>> I mean that's what I was kind of angled
at at the end of last year, right? With
the studio in New York and interviewing
like people and
>> trying to do like
>> Wonder if anything changed since last
year that's made him totally radioactive
to any serious political actor. I wonder
if there's like things that have
happened in the past month that have
made him even more radioactive to every
single person in these spheres.
Justifiably so.
>> Yeah, that was the angle. Yeah.
>> Okay. But then that's that's the problem
though is we keep getting wrapped in the
um which is funny. I'm not I'm not going
to like I obviously watch the drama
content, but if we keep
>> Never mind.
>> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> No, you said it was funny. Go ahead. I
was making asy joke. You're good. the
but but the point is though um they're
there
>> yeah Conor's a obviously Connor thinks
Connor is just on the page by the way
Andrew Wilson's on the same page they're
basically on the same page as Wes
they're like anybody who was willing to
engage in any consensual relationship
with Destiny should have known that they
would get raped that like like he is
such a degenerate piece of they should
have just known that their consent would
be violated that's what Connor believes
like 100% that's Connor that's Andrew
Wilson that's like Wes that like if you
engage with this guy at all, you should
know he is such an obvious piece of [__]
that like, you know, your consent would
be violated. That how he manages to
transfer that condemnation that he
should have for Destiny onto Destiny's
victims, that's like a it's a gymnastics
act I can't describe. I can't
understand, but even minors uh
>> organizations. So, for instance, I don't
know if they're going to want me to
bring up their name, but effectively
like
>> Don't do that.
>> Probably not.
>> Never mind.
>> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> No, you said it was funny. Go ahead. I
was making joke. You're good.
>> The But but the point is though, um
there there are organizations. So for
instance, I don't know if they're going
to want me to bring up their name, but
effectively like
>> don't do that.
>> Don't do that.
>> Probably not.
>> Probably not. I think they told me to.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> What? I don't know what you're going to
say.
>> I know what I'm going to say, which is
it's a
>> the manboy association.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> No, I'm just kidding.
>> No, what I was going to say is that
there's like Okay. Number one, uh I
don't know if PB is doing anything for
midterms. Number two, um the uh the
national ground game and so
>> so this is America.
>> National ground game is I met Z Cohen
Sanchez in DC and she's trying to get
Democrat donors to back her project and
what she wants to do is she wants to
replicate
>> um Turning Points USA but for the
Democrats and so that's what she's
trying to do. And so for me, uh, taking
Twitch and YouTube politics energy.
>> Hey, Connor. Uh, you're going to go talk
to Destiny about rating this person,
this like lollycon person. They like
drawing pictures of kids. They've
stated, uh, that they desire to have a
12-year-old wrapped around their waist
that you're going to go talk about that.
And then what I want you to do right
after that is bring up National Ground
Game, bring up on America. I want you to
hard tie the name Z. Cohen Sanchez to
Steven Bennell and all the things Steven
Bennell does. If you could do that for
me, Connor, I would
love that. Thank you very much, Connor.
I appreciate it, buddy. I appreciate you
>> starting uh mirror chapters to the
Republicans with Democrats.
>> Creating cool debate events and then
having Twitch and YouTube political
content show up for debate events and
canvasing operations. That's the next
step.
>> Yeah, I agree. I think Yeah, I think
it's a cool project. It's the reason I
did stuff with them before. Yeah.
>> Okay. Well,
>> it's like related to the America stuff
kind of, right?
>> Okay. Okay. So, so how is it even
possible though to like divorce Twitch
and YouTube politics away from this and
move into the real stuff or is it just
so
>> No, it's not possible because
unfortunately Counter Boys, if you had
any empathy, it's not possible because
all of you guys are involved. He he
literally a bunch of the people who have
had their consent violated are people
who were involved in his community or in
his political. That's that's before, by
the way. That's before the child stuff,
okay? Which is obviously standing on its
own is something different. Uh if he
hadn't used his community to find these
people, then maybe you have like a
different conversation, but there's no
reason when there are all these other
people who could be involved in this.
There's no reason to have Destiny
involved in this. You just there's just
no reason.
>> Like
>> I would say there's one way to do it.
>> Um but I mean it's I guess it's easy and
convenient for me to say it, but like
people just have to ignore it. But
people are not capable of doing that
right now because there's so much
pressure from these people and people
feel like they have to have a position
on it or they have to respond to it or
they have to do something. Like I give a
lot of props to I give props to you and
I give a lot of props to Wick for
resisting a lot of it. But it's really
hard when you've got like Z that Z's
been doxed on QB farms. People are
spreading all of her [__] around. I've
had like I've seen three of my fans get
doxed in the last two weeks. People who
just like tweet and people like found
their names and then are like posting
their jobs and [__] One of the guys
emailed me and said call the cops. So I
like that's I mean like
>> well I mean I called the cops within the
past week and it wasn't even that I got
like specific threats or whatever but I
called my local law enforcement and I
just said hey everybody's like we're
effectively in a doxing war right now.
>> Yeah. It's it's amazing. I'm sitting
here. Okay. I'm basically like
Greenland. I'm like incapable of off I
don't have like the ability to do any of
this. Right. And I'm being told I'm in a
doxy war and like America is missiles at
me and I'm like no I didn't I can't do
anything. What are you what's happening?
And then a bunch of the people in like
Europe who are supposed to have my back
and like be at the UN, they're just
like, "Well, America said this is
happening." And uh yeah, it's just a
doxing war. I don't know what to tell
you, buddy. I don't know what to I don't
know. Yeah, sorry. You're just going to
get hit with these missiles now. I'm
like, "What the I didn't do." I ker I
don't have any idea. I assume if they're
talking about people getting docked or
something, he says Kiwi Farms, I assume
it's anonymous people on Kiwi Farms who
I have no control over or connection to.
And trust me, in terms of, hey, if they
had some interventions, they're like,
hey, if you uh if you could just not
show people on stream or if you could
like do this, I'd be willing to to take
into account, oh, maybe this happening
and maybe I should be a little more um
what do you call it? Like a little more
careful not to make people targets or I
could understand that maybe, right? But
what I'm not willing to do is drop all
of these topics or like stop talking
about anything that's important to me
because Kiwi Farms is doing something.
I'm not going to let that element of it
control me. Okay, if there's like a
concern that like, oh, a couple of my
chatters are docks or something, if I
felt like I could do something to take
pressure off of those people without
compromising my opinion at all, I'd
absolutely do that, right? I'm
absolutely willing to do that, right?
But it depends, okay? Because if you're
if you're one of the people who is a
Destiny Chatter who's like trying to
spread what they think is docs of me and
I'm like annoyed with you or I I like
point that out on stream that you're
like trying to dox people, like I don't
know what to tell you. I don't think I
should not cover that either, right? So,
it would all just depend on how this
going. Anyway, I don't I don't control
things. If I felt like my stream was a
vehicle for this in some way, if I felt
that, I would probably take precautions
against that. So, we'll see cuz I've
been told that apparently there's some
argument here that like uh I brought up
a chatter and they got doxed or
something, which uh if that happened, I
would have to take appropriate measures.
If somebody was going to target people I
was just annoyed with or something, I'd
have to think about something there,
right? I don't that doesn't put blame on
me. By the way, if I'm if I'm like
calling out some justifi justifiable to
call out behavior, I'm not going to say
that's my fault that something bad
happened to that person. Okay. What I'm
saying is if I felt like, oh well, I
shouldn't show this on stream or I need
to censor names or something. Maybe
there's some some consideration there,
right? Is a reason he just says that he
doesn't show proof. Oh, I would think
I'm saying if I could see some proof of
this happening, then I'd be interested.
Uh I would consider it. But if it's just
like oh uh if it's just by the way I'm
just gonna say no I'm not saying you
didn't say it was from our community.
I'm saying if it was KF or something
creger but like what I won't do is I'm
not going to like not cover Destiny's or
something. I'm not going to like I'm not
going to sacrifice my coverage or change
my opinion to protect people who are
engaging in like like conduct, right?
I'm not going to do that. I I can't
control Kiwi Farms. I don't have that
ability. I have zero ability to do that.
Right. And the people on there who've
been doxing people, I have zero ability
because all the people who dox people
close to Destiny have been doing that
since way before I was against Destiny.
Okay. The fear I had of Kiwi Farms in
December of 2024 was that they would dox
me for being a fan of Destiny, for being
like close to Destiny. Okay.
But almost everybody who's been doxed
around Destiny was doxed before that
point. So that's that's all I'm saying
is like this this force has been doing
it regardless of who's covering Destiny
negatively regardless of what what's
been going on. They've been doing that
for a while now. To put that on me or to
put it on Queen or to put it on anybody
is insane.
Why these people don't harass me anymore
and it's cuz I don't care and I don't
give them attention. Uh but if they find
that they have some
>> Bro, are you serious? Cuz I don't give
them attention. Guys, it's just it's
just because I don't give them any
attention at all. Okay, I don't give
them any attention.
Oh, hold on. Where's my thing? Oh, hold
on. Where is it? Here. Occurred. Just go
to my Twitter. I'm going to go find the
the of him with Rose. And I'm just going
to pull it up again. I don't give them
attention. He says he says he doesn't
give them attention. You just go down to
the tweet. Where's the tweet at? Where's
the tweet at? Not that one. I'll find
it. I'll find it. There we go. There we
go. Right. I don't give any attention to
this. While he posts PII, fullfaced
pictures, the College of Rose, all of
this, fully engages with Kiwi Farms.
Kiwi Farm's ability to investigate
anything is super pathetic. He's
taunting them directly, right? I don't,
guys, I don't engage with these people
at all. So, when I don't engage, they'll
go after the people around me. Shut the
up. It's so crazy. Oh, whoops. This is a
Willy Mac video. Let's No, that's not it
either. What did I Hold on. Did I just
Did I really do that? No the where did I
just shift off of this window right
here. Thank you.
>> All you maybe
hold on. Where was this me? We're
somewhere around here.
>> We'll just have to ignore it. But people
are not capable of doing that right now
cuz there's so much pressure from these
people and people feel like they have to
have a position. And by the way, I don't
give a like at these drama farmers. But
then for me, I'm worried that actually
>> behavior don't do it again. Like I think
it's the easiest thing in the world. we
get some kind of like pragmatic result
out of it or maybe
>> I for some reason clicked off of this
window. I don't know why I did this.
>> But you don't let enemies try to like
weaponize these,
>> but it's water off a
>> they have some success in other outlets.
People don't harass me anymore cuz I
don't care and I don't give them
attention. Uh but if they find that they
have some success in other outlets, as
soon as they see any success there,
that's what they lean into. But like
notice right now, you'll never see
somebody approach uh like nobody talks
about Trump's cases, his
>> nobody talks about like the Tates to any
of these conservative guys because they
know cuz why? Well, I mean like even
listen,
>> I do. But it's water off a duck.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Cuz they don't give a
[__] about it. They don't care, right?
>> Interviewing the Tates was insane.
>> Why won't you guys just let me be a
predator like the conservatives let
Andrew Tate do? Why won't you guys just
let ignore me keeping child on my hard
drives like you like everybody lets
conservatives do? Why won't you just let
me
Okay, let him He makes these arguments
like totally unapologetically totally
just with no no introspection, no
thought, he'll just make these
arguments.
>> Yeah. So, I think that like we should
have our own like moral standards or
whatever, but like those are things that
you hold yourself to account to and then
other people who you Hold on. Are the
people who you care about who are near
you like hold you to account to these?
But you don't let enemies try to like
weaponize these against you, which is
what happens. And it works so well cuz
so many people get you the the reason
why enemies quote unquote talk about
this stuff is because you lie about it.
You lie and and defame people and you
lie and harass people. Like you can't
stop lying. Let's not forget he fully
confessed to non-consensually sending
Pixie tapes to this 17-year-old. He
totally confessed to straight away that
he did it non-consensually and he just
lies and says, "No, no, no. That's not
what I meant. I just meant like I was,
you know, I was sad it leaked. That's
all I meant, guys." He just lies. So,
yes, if you're just going to lie and
harm people all the way along, then
yeah, third parties have to come in.
It's not just, "Oh, well, my loved ones
won't hold me accountable." Turns out
the only people you let into your inner
circle are complete and utter sick
offenses. Anybody who was in a total
sick event has left. every other person
held you accountable by walking away
from you. We got so caught up in it.
Yeah.
>> My question though because obviously um
I'm feeling pressure from a variety of
sources and by the way I don't give a
like at the so so yeah to some degree I
obviously care like the I talk to these
people in DMs or in replies and um it's
not nice when people call you bad names
on the internet. Um however ultimately I
still have a life outside of this [__]
>> Sure. Not to trivialize though. It's not
just that. It's like spam calls to
people's jobs and
>> a lot of other people have experience
worship than me.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um but but the point is though, how do
you know that? Because when you're so
for instance like Benny Johnson or
whatever or um you've talked
>> uh no anemone Dan's still like around in
chat and stuff. Okay. He just doesn't
want the rep of hanging out with the
child guy.
>> That's all. He's just trying to avoid
that rep as best he can. He's totally
friends with Destiny. He's got no
problem with Destiny or any of his
conduct, right? Otherwise, he would have
made a statement. Destiny said that Dan
has no problem with what he did. And
Dan's never contradicted that. So, I
don't know how you could possibly assume
Dan has any problem with it.
>> Talk to him. The Hodge Twins.
>> Mhm.
>> So, the Hodge Twins talked to Andrew
Tate in my opinion and Benny Johnson
talked to Andrew Tate number one because
they knew that they would get the clout,
influence, money, etc., but also because
they knew that they would trigger the
lips. And so, principles didn't matter
ultimately because they were going to
stick by their team. not because it was
good to stick by their team but because
uh they knew that they would get some
kind of like pragmatic result out of it.
So I guess my question is how do you how
do you balance
uh calling out moral failures of people
and also allowing like descriptive
reality to exist along with not allowing
political projects to die because you're
getting sucked into the drama
>> trivially easy thing to do. I don't
think it's a
>> like what? It's trivially easy. How?
>> Trivially easy. You tell somebody like,
"Oh, I think hey what
>> you just tell somebody. If you think
somebody [__] up, they say, "Hey, I
think you [__] up." Like, change this
behavior. Don't do it again. Like, I
think it's the easiest thing in the
world.
>> Uh, how many times can Destiny
nonconensually share videos before other
people just go, you know what? I don't
think you're learning this lesson or
content, nudes, actual poor. How many
times can he do this before it's like,
"Oh, no. You're actually you're actually
not helpable. You actually could keep
doing it world to do.
>> Okay. But what if what if we disagree on
something? So for instance, like I
>> we can have disagreements. If there is a
disagreement where like the moral
disagreement is so huge
>> that you like I can't I don't think I
can be a part of this then you separate.
But like I mean every movement is going
to have people who have like fundamental
moral disagreements. That happens. But
there are going to be some things that
you draw the line around where it's like
this is too much. Like I can't like this
person might be pro-choice and this
person might be pro- life. Generally
speaking, depending on these people can
probably work together, but if a guy was
like pro murderer or this guy was like
pro like there are some things where
it's like this is like a bridge to where
I can't on that. Yeah.
>> But I I'll tell you just you know face
to face that that line for me is almost
hit by food shops and the reason why is
because like so
>> almost almost.
>> So I get it like um pragmatic reasons
you're using I keep saying this you're
not saying this. comes. Uh guys, we're
uh we're coming up on the 2hour mark
left on the stream. Been going for a
couple hours here. We just crossed the 4
hour mark on the stream. If you guys
like the content, I want you to go ahead
and follow on every platform. Follow on
axe. Follow on Twitch. Join the Discord.
discord.gg/jstlk.
Join the Discord right now. Okay? Join,
join, join. And if you really like the
content, you want the content to go on
for longer, you can donate, guys.
There's a couple ways you can do that.
You can sub on kick. You can sub on
Twitch. You can give subs on kick.
Subbing on kick is the best way to sub.
Okay. 955 split on kick. It's the best.
All right. Twitch is 50/50. Kick is 955.
95 going to me. All right. You can also
buy a TTS message. Buy a TTS message
through Kickbot. Buy a TTS message
through Streamlabs. All right. All
dollars donated these ways goes towards
more time on the stream. We are about uh
let's say seven subs away from another
hour on the stream. Appreciate all the
support, guys. What's the split on
Patreon? It's not that great, but I
still appreciate the Patreon most of
all, okay? Cuz the Patreon's on a
different thing, guys. Last but not
least, there's the Patreon.
patreon.com/jdlk.
If you want to help, you know, fight
against perspective future homelessness.
There's a couple different tiers over on
the Patreon. There's the $5 tier. This
gets you, I think, soundboards in the
Discord and some some different priority
things in the Discord. $25 tier is for
additional content that will materialize
one one day, okay? At some point in the
in the near near future. All right,
guys. $100 tier. Do not sign up for this
tier unless you have unless you earn
more than six figures a month. Okay, but
there's a couple different tiers of the
Patreon. All right, I appreciate all of
the Patreon members. 35 an hour is the
current I think it's 45 an hour is the
current rate. 45 per hour.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. First first two
hours are 30 each. All right. Some
comedic relief. Hold on. Some comedic
relief. Quick pallet cleanser with the
with the Shuvi guy. We're going to get
back to the Connor conversation in just
a second, guys. Is this just the Hold
on. Is this going to be
>> What the dude metal?
>> Oh, this is really Shuy. Really, Shuy?
>> I'm the joke.
>> Dude, get somebody at kick needs to get
Shuy like a like a hardware show, okay?
Of him just building. Him just being
Macgyver and building [__] This is
awesome content every single time. Okay.
What the [__] dude? Metal just sprayed
in my face, bro. I don't even know what
to say, dude.
>> He literally hears the drill like
kicking around over here or something
and he puts his fingers right where the
screws are coming through.
>> What a guy. What a what a guy this guy.
>> What the [__] bro?
>> Smart guy this guy.
>> Amazing. Big things happening on guys.
Big things. All right, we're back to the
Connor Desty conversation. Let's
continue. Um, you're using her as a
weapon against Jto and Queen because
let's face it, she can a log them uh
pretty well. So, you're using her as a
weapon against these.
>> What he's actually using food shops as
is a like an IQ check for his community.
That's what he's actually he I can't
believe that he doesn't see this that
like by sending people over there, he's
like only filtering down to the worst
most useless cultists, right? Like she
is an embarrassing person. She is not
capable of making arguments. Zip Zip is
an embarrassing person. You've
surrounded yourself with total re and
like I got to imagine if there was
anybody left who had some intelligence,
who had some like interesting opinions,
who was going to be of use to you in
some way in the future, they've got to
see the Zip Zip and Food Shop show and
just go like, uh, no, no, no thanks. Not
just his audience, for Connor too, to
further humiliate Connor is possible. is
drama farmers. But then for me, I'm
worried that actually unironically that
that tweet that she put out as a joke,
which I understand to be a joke, is that
she'll get 500 viewers, thousand
viewers, whatever, and then she'll
normalize that viewership within her
community, and there'll be half a dozen
to a few dozen souls who will just fall
into what I view as like a spiritual
trap, uh, which is being a lollyconer. I
think that's unironically a spiritual
trap.
I think it's hell.
>> Gotcha.
>> So, I don't want people to go into hell.
>> Okay.
>> So, how do we stop that?
>> I I don't know argue against today. I
don't I just don't have that huge of a
position on it that I cared as much
about it.
>> But, I mean, if I did, then maybe I
would feel stronger about it. I think if
it was a larger part of her content, I'm
going to be honest, I've never actually
>> Actually, I think I did hear her argue
about this. I think like a year ago,
that's why I removed it from cuz I just
didn't want to whatever.
>> Two years ago.
>> Yeah. But it's like if it was like every
day it was like here's the 30 minute you
know lolli praise preaching segment. I'd
be like okay this is kind of weird. I
think this is too much. Then I probably
you know I think I'm good on that one.
But I I don't know maybe this is maybe
this was a or is a big part of the
content. I've just never seen it before.
But
>> well I haven't seen it recently. Uh to
be honest I I think what what ended up
happening or at least been pointed out
to me by people is the fact that two
years ago in my opinion it was a large
part of the content.
>> Okay.
>> I freaked out and yelled at Chud and
then they're like why aren't you yelling
at Stephen? So,
>> well,
>> this is that conversation,
>> but I'm not I'm not pro lolly and I
don't support Lolly in my community.
>> I know, but
>> I don't have people posting LOI. That's
not in any of my That would always be
against the rules every rhyme at.
>> But it's like,
>> wait, why did movies get banned in EG
again? Can someone does anyone know why
movies got banned in DG? Does anybody
remember any knowowers? Any knowowers
participating in the knowers, noticers?
Anyone? the the raid, then the watching
the drama content, and then
>> now I will say they handled that
appropriately by being like, "Okay, [__]
stop." But I'm just saying
>> building a platform and then maybe fall
some people fall into her perspective.
So, it's like a three consequence
series.
>> Yeah. Nobody their side is never
following that. I would never kneecap my
side by having to
>> wait wait wait
and then the raid then the watching the
drama content and then build
>> Wait one wait hold on one second
>> and yelled at Chud and then they're like
why aren't you yelling at Steven so
>> well
>> this is that conversation
>> but I'm I'm not I'm not pro lolly and I
don't spot lolly in my community
>> I know but
>> like I don't have people posting lolli
that's not in any of my [__] that would
always be against the rules every rhyme
I'm at
>> but it's like the the raid
then the watching the drama content and
then building a platform and
>> uh
how do I say this? Someone was
delivering food and uh and Cherry went
to the door and she didn't recognize or
she she didn't see that the guy was
there. She just saw like the ding had
happened and he was like standing there
apparently spooked her. I don't know if
you guys even heard she kind of yelled.
Sorry if you're wondering. I was like
what the they found us.
>> They didn't find us. and then maybe fall
some people fall into her perspective.
So, it's like a three
>> I hope you guys didn't hear that one.
>> Jesus consequence.
>> Sorry, I have to actually listen to what
Connor is saying here. I do want to hear
>> I I have to listen.
>> I'm not pro lolly and I don't lolly in
my community.
>> We're locked in.
>> I know, but
>> I don't have people posting lolly.
That's not in any of my [__] That would
always be against the rules ever.
>> But it's like the the raid then the
watching the drama content and then
building a platform and then maybe
follow some people. him acting like this
is no big deal. I'm fine with him acting
like it's no big deal. Uh he's just
being honest. He doesn't care, right? I
think I think the like total
disengagement with um how Connor feels
about this like and mocking him for it.
I think that's telling and then uh I
don't know like it's basically
reminding Connor over and over again
that he's never going to rise to the
moral level of moral character that
Connor wants him to. And the his entire
Connor<unk>'s entire pursuit is like
worthless here. fall into her
perspective. So, it's like a three
consequence series.
>> Yeah. Nobody their side is never
following that. I would never kneecap my
side by having to have them weaponize
all of those principles. And Chloe was
jerking it to some 15-year-old. He was a
long time ago anyway. So, who the [__]
cares?
>> I have to defend his honor. She was 17
and she lied about her age.
>> Oh, that mattered for Chud, didn't it?
Wasn't there one other
uh did Chud get from that girl and then
keep that after he'd heard that she was
under the age of 18?
>> Did Chud do that? I'm just curious. I I
forget if I missed it. Did Chud do that?
>> Other big streamer that came out and
defended him on that?
>> Yes. Truth. Huh?
>> Yeah. Well, okay. It was Xanderhal.
>> What? No, it was me.
>> I know.
>> Oh, you Also,
>> Xanderhal was our base defender, our M
King.
>> I know, but Xanderhal unironically
defended Chud during that drama as well.
>> Sure.
>> So, no. And
>> to be clear, I didn't defend Chud
because I thought he was innocent. I
just hate 17-year-olds.
>> Right. Okay. Anyways, so um I think I'm
trying to think of how people are
looking at this. No, no, no, no, no.
Okay. I think uh I think a lot of people
would have actually if this was the only
thing that happened with Destiny, right?
I think a lot of people would have
defended him on this on up until the
point where he kept the videos, right? A
lot more people would have. The problem
is it's all of this coming back to back
to back to back, right? Like you have
the the actual consent violations, the
sending non-consensually, the recording
uh audio non-conensually, you have like
all these things coming like he's losing
different cohorts of his audience with
all of these things as they find out
about it. Right. Anyway,
>> okay. So the so the point is
>> I think people would have defended him
on this to be honest. You're okay.
You're saying that you can call out the
bad behavior.
>> So, up until he keeps it after he finds
out the age, after he gets an indication
she's a minor
>> on your side, when it hits when it
crosses a moral perspective that you
can't deal with anymore, that's when you
can separate. Um, then you said that the
real point of Twitch or what should be
the real point of Twitch and YouTube
politics should be carving off two to 5%
of the energy, money, time, and
attention and putting it into canvasing
events, volunteering, election.
>> We can do more than that. Ideally, I
would have liked to funnel all of my
online stuff into kind of like political
power oriented stuff, but obviously that
got the brakes pumped on it when little
Miss and her friend decided to go in
federal court. So,
>> well, okay, but let's say it's a year
from now or two years from now. Uh, and
the distance between you and these
issues has expanded.
>> Um, are you going to revive that dream?
>> Uh, yeah. I mean, like I said, now I'm
in the tendril planting phase where I'm
reaching out more and building a
connections again. Um, I'll I just have
to see what the vibes are in a couple
months or whatever and keep pushing
forward. Yeah. Do you think Okay, but do
you think that most people like le let's
say that um Jtock or Cleman are like hey
um Stephen is prodoxing doxing me and
they're using a lollycon in order to do
it.
>> Self-defense doxing to be fair, but go
ahead.
>> Okay. Defensive doxing.
>> Defensive doxing. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that's probably something we
that's actually probably the next topic
we should talk about because I feel like
we've already summarized it and so at
this point I'm kind of moral frogging.
Okay.
>> Um so, let's move on from the moral
frogging. Defensive doxing. The other
thing that I'm getting called out for is
the fact that I said two or three years
ago. It was in reference to Kevin
Cassley who's actually disappeared uh as
far as I know.
>> Damn. Did you get docks?
>> Um, no. But he was like a neoliberal
guy. I think he was neoliberal. I think
he turned into a Trump sickopant. I
forget. But effectively Kevin Cassley,
somebody brought it to my attention that
Kevin Cassley was going out of his way
to dock some of his critics. He was like
looking up their personal information
and sending it to them in DMs. And I was
like, "Okay, this is super up. You're
basically threatening
harassment/swatting
over internet beef. This is very dumb.
Um, and basically this should be the
line where nobody crosses it. However,
excuse me, the accusations from Jtocking
Queen is that you're not engaged in
defensive doxing. You're throwing [__]
at the wall and seeing what sticks.
>> Me?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I've only doxed people that are
unhinged and obsessed about me. I'm
pretty sure every person I've done has
been one of those people. Have you done
it or have you gotten gay ops people in
DGG or gay ops people in different
discords to do it?
>> Combination of both, but if somebody
passes out to me, I'll post it. I don't
give a queen. I'm looking for Doobie.
Careful. Um,
>> Dubis,
what did Doobie do to you?
>> The unhinged obsessive weird
workshopping with all these disgusting
losers in the background. I think it's
gross and weird. I've seen him type
unhinged disgusting weird about me and
like all these um just had more logs to
me sent today about it. What if he
thinks you're genuinely
>> Can you give an example?
>> Can you send that to Wick and be like,
"Is this a direct threat now to do?"
>> No, Wick doesn't care. Wick doesn't
care.
>> But this is as direct as it gets.
>> Yeah. I mean, he's he I'm I'm sorry. It
was already direct before, but yes,
you're right. This is more direct. This
is more pointed. It won't matter.
>> No,
>> it won't. Dude, if it had any chance of
mattering, I would I would care. Also,
I'm not going to be the person who does
it, you know? It's just wild. Listen to
Cherry. Guys, I don't know if you
realize this. I'm not going to go around
to people and tell them like, "You have
to stop hanging out with this guy." I
already let Connor know when he's a
total moral degenerate. Okay, that's as
far as I'm willing to go is just going
like, "Hey, Connor, I think your
conscience will kick in eventually."
Right. Eventually.
>> I'm looking for
>> Yeah, I know. I know what you're saying,
Cherry. I know what you're saying.
>> For Doobie, careful. Um,
>> Doobie, who else?
>> We're looking for Doobie. Be careful.
Uh, what is
>> the unhinged obsessive weird uh
workshopping with all these disgusting
losers in the background? I think it's
gross and weird. I've seen him type
unhinged disgusting weird about me and
like all these um service. I just had
more logs to me sent today about it.
>> What if he thinks you're genuinely evil
though? What what like what if Jtock
Queen and uh because this is an argument
that I've heard them bring up or
whatever. They're like, "Oh, Stephen
thinks that there there's this
conspiracy to take him out, but the
conspiracy is the fact that we don't
like him and we think he's a bad guy and
he sucks and he should go down." That's
the
>> If you want to have that if you want to
have that like opinion of me, I think
that's fine. But when it gets to the
point where you're obsessively
facilitating conversations about um like
my dating partners or whatever,
everybody associated with that, like all
those people. The only person who did
that excessively was Kelly Jean and that
is somebody he likes now because she
doesn't like me or Cherry. The only
person who's done that was Kelly and
he's explicitly said we don't talk about
Kelly anymore. I It's like it's so
disingenuous. He is just so disingenuous
all of the time. It's so funny. Well, by
the way, nothing he could do in response
to Kelly on his girlfriend beyond just
talking back would be justifiable. Okay,
it's on the internet. Don't be a
>> or when you start like obsessively
talking about like my kid. Uh or when
you start obsessively like when you're
like reading out like my revenge or
making fun of like stuff
>> like I just see this is the thing is I'm
sure this sounds compelling to Connor in
some way, right? I'm sure this could be
this could sound compelling to Connor
somehow maybe. Right. But when he says,
"Oh, when you read out my revenge Yeah.
We don't talk about his kid." And then
he says, "When you read out my wrench,
he has leaked DMs with multiple women."
He has read out DMs from reviews for
multiple women. He does not believe this
is a bar. It only applies to him. It is
it is only a rule when it comes to him.
And it's it's apparently also only
really a rule when it comes to him this
minor. That's where it all of a sudden
everything changed on this. Although
actually I guess technically when
Adavore was going to out him as a
manipulative like evil piece of [__] he
did also do it there right if you if you
leak my I might have some photos of you
I'll leak related like leaked on that
then no police I don't give a [__] um
>> there's two things that Stephen actually
did show me that I actually found kind
of disturbing today uh number one um
somebody who used to be an orbiter
reading out Steven's specific address
that
>> Wait I showed you this today or
>> I think you did
>> oh oh the oh
>> uh Lord Don is unhinged Shut. I don't
know why the [__] he do that. That was
insane. That was an insane thing to do.
>> Um, yeah. Not justified, by the way.
>> Lauren de Laguna.
>> Yeah. Wasane.
>> Although, yeah. No, not justified. Um,
I'm trying to think. Apparently, some
happened where Lauren is no longer a
public defender. I I still don't think
she'd be justified doing that to Destiny
if she uh suspected he had a hand in
that or something. And she would need
some evidence of it. She can't just go
do it. So,
>> correct. Specifically
>> on a show. Just says it. Yeah.
>> On a show. saying the exact address,
which like for me it's like, okay, you
want him to get harassed, stabbed, shot,
murdered, whatever. So that's bananas.
And then number two was the spreadsheet,
which is basically
>> Oh, Jesus. Yeah. Don't even Yeah. But
yeah, it's just creepy and weird. It's
stalker.
>> Trying to document all of your friends,
all of your
>> like the age of every girl I've ever
known. Yeah. It's weird and creepy.
>> And so for me,
>> and these guys like on all these other
people, they play into it. Like I I
don't do the um I joked about like the
being Dexter, whatever. These guys all
play into it. He just made a massive
statement, right, with no evidence. And
Connor doesn't think to pause and go,
"Hey, I should What do you mean they all
play into it?" What do you mean they all
play into it? What does playing into it
even mean? Connor doesn't need to know.
Connor wants to believe, right? Connor
is in the cult. He doesn't want to
actually figure this out. It's just
entirely performative on his part. He's
just saying he will just listen. He will
go, "Oh, yeah. Yeah. Tell me tell me
exactly what I what what to say, what to
think." There's no curiosity there.
There's nothing. He needs to have heard
the counter talking point. If he hasn't
heard me or Quimman program him because
he needs some father figure in his life,
he hasn't heard the actual counter
talking point. He has no idea how to
even engage in intellectual curiosity
when Destiny speaks to him.
>> Ever earlier like murdering people, but
I would never do that. Yeah, never
murder people. Um, not yet. But the like
the it's the there's like a game that
works when you're being you ever watch
Mine Black 3?
>> Uh no, but we've talked about it.
>> There's a game that works where you can
be kind of cutesy like Justicle and
Queman are very good at being like
Twinky cutesy where they're like, "Oh,
show me in my community where somebody
posted the docs or whatever." And that
works for like normies, but I'm not like
I'm not going to sit here and play that
game. So if I have information about
you, if I can get your accounts banned,
reported docs, whatever, I'll do that
all day 100%. There's a reason, by the
way, why just had to clean his Discord
chat and why so many of their accounts
keep getting banned, by the way. But
yeah,
>> because he's mass reporting my Discord.
Yeah, we know you're forgetting the
Discord. Obviously, we knew that
already. That's Everybody knew that.
Yeah.
>> Uh-huh.
>> As an example, though, um somebody else,
not you,
>> by the way, just fully admitting that
he's bringing in the Discord, right?
which whatever I guess
>> um showed me uh evidence that uh a known
Kiwi farmer uh personality
>> was in spicy chat known to be in spicy
chat. One of the profiles got banned and
they had an alt with the same PFP but a
different name and there were like DMs
or logs or whatever where basically they
were like oh yeah that's me lol. And
then they kept operating within spicy
chat under the same name.
>> Wait, have you told me this? Uh, no.
Somebody else did.
>> Do I know this person?
>> Um, yeah.
>> By the way, that standard for Desty's
behavior, I'm sure that couldn't
possibly be applied to like just so we
know. Okay. I don't advocate for this. I
don't want I don't think there's any
reason, by the way, with regards to the
Kylo stuff. I don't think there's any
reason that she should be taken off of
YouTube. Her contents, as far as I can
tell, totally fine for YouTube. I have
no reason why. No understanding of why
it happened, right? But I am just
telling you that like what he just said,
oh yeah, I don't care. I'm not going to
play this game. I know you're guilty of
this. Now he's just totally justified
people going after his friends in this
exact way, right? Which is so stupid,
but he wants that. He wants all those
people negatively. The only way he can
keep friends is if they're scared of a
bigger boogeyman and they think Desi's
going to protect them, right? That's the
only thing that keeps people close to
him right now. And then there's Connor
who's like Lenny on the farm. Okay.
Desi's like, "Yeah, I'll tell you about
I'll tell you about the farm again.
We're going to have one day Connor." And
Connor's like, "Tell me about the
bunnies, David." You know, but other
than Connor, everybody else, they just
think they're being protected from like
a bigger boogeyman. So, he wants he
wants these people scared. He wants
other people to go hard on them, right?
He needs to paint the boogeyman. I don't
care to be that boogeyman. I don't want
I don't want Erdite banned, right? For
from no for no reason other than Okay.
Okay. There are other reasons, but the
the first reason I would give you is
just that it's really good money to
watch her and watch her like humiliate
herself. That's incredible money. Yeah,
she got terminated from YouTube. They're
going to bring it up later in this as
well, but I don't I don't think she
deserves that. I don't think she should
be banned. Uh I like totally disagree
with it. But Desi's out here fully
advocating for like trying to deplatform
people who have criticisms for him.
>> So I can show it to you later.
>> Oh jeez. I know there are a lot of pe I
know there I there's at least two people
who have a heavy presence on Kiwi Farms
and Inress Fields community and I know
they know they'll deny it if I say it
but yeah but so yeah the'll deny. So
just tell me all he has to do is say it
unless he's just going to like cuz when
he says presence he has to mean posting
right he can't mean reading. There's no
way he could just mean reading because
obviously he reads Kiwi Farms all the
time. Everybody around him reads Kiwi
Farms all the time, right? I don't think
he could possibly just mean reading. I
think it has to mean interacting and
like like actually participating in some
way.
>> Absolutely. And everybody knows like
this is like a thing again where like um
>> Well, and to be clear, my evidence is 2
years old.
>> Sure. But I'm saying like this is a
thing where like you can kind of like be
cutesy if you're talking to other
people, but like everybody knows. It's
like open cigarettes. Yeah. Well, and
then so here here's the line because I'm
trying to put this together and bear in
mind like the what is it like don't
touch the poo is the
>> that used to be the thing for keepers.
My thread is very special. They are they
take an active part in trying to be
involved in my life. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the old
>> they don't and Destiny was totally fine
with the Keville's thread existing and
defended the Keville's thread existing
when they're doxing everyone around
Keels. This guy is just transparently
like zero principles, right? Oh, it's
happening to me now. It's bad. That's
all it is. old rule is, you know, don't
touch the poo, don't harass people,
don't dox them, don't swat them, etc.,
etc. That was the old rule.
>> Um, so for me, I'm still trying to play.
>> No, there was never a rule against Kiwi
Farms has always been a doxing
community. They've always been a place
where you can post docs. Docs is not the
same. Having docs there is not the same
as uh like actually interacting. Yes,
that's never been a rule.
>> Like, don't touch the poo because I
don't want to know. I don't want to know
who these people are. And I barely want
them.
>> By the way, Destiny is completely making
up that his thread is special. His
thread is not special. Other threads are
the exact same as his. The Keell's
thread is almost certainly at its height
far worse than Destiny's thread. Like
far more like cutting, far more, you
know, hateful of them. Like I I don't
think Destiny's thread really stands up
to the Keville's thread in any way.
Keville's thread was like printing off
like a 100 pages an hour. That [__] was
insane. All right.
>> Know me. M um but the the point though
is so so we have let's say that we have
kiwi farms and the way
>> oh that is true wired rope that is
actually true his is special because he
does directly interact with it that's
true
>> talk about it is that it's a uh it's a
place where they effectively a log
somebody's information but then it does
get weird where for instance revenge is
posted maintained until it's asked to be
talked down or brought down um addresses
are posted they're left up until they're
brought
No, they're just left up.
>> Okay. Phone numbers are posted. Left up.
>> There's a popular
>> That [__] was That's how Kiwi Farms has
always been. Unless I'm mistaken. Is
this not how Kiwi Farms has always been?
>> Leftist account, I think, that posted
some audio of me sucking some dude off
yesterday on his Twitter account. Nobody
gives a Yeah, it's all memes. Yeah.
>> So, sorry, I I blinked just to
>> Yeah, it's all good times. Yeah.
>> Um, so so anyway, so they leave that
stuff up and then the the thing is like
they're like, "Oh, well, we don't docks.
We don't harass." But realistically, if
you wanted to harass somebody, if you
wanted to swat somebody, that's where
you would find it.
>> 100%. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> So then, but that's not illegal to have
that information up,
>> right?
>> Then you have Discords, which probably
do have stricter I don't know what the
terms of service are, but they probably
have do have stricter.
>> Yeah. You can't I think you'll get
banned for that. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, they have they have stricter
things. And so, what'll happen is, at
least as far as I understand, is the
Discords are places where people like
chat [__] talk about internet
personality.
>> Yeah. We can point out that obviously
it's a non-conensually recorded audio in
that case as well. Yes, it obviously is.
He's talking about the He's almost
certainly talking about the
non-consentually recorded Grinder audio.
He was talking about anime. That was
actually one of the funny things is one
of the times that I was checking in on a
Discord that was talking about me and
talking about you. Um, they got
distracted by anime and they talked
about anime for like 24 hours and then
they went back to talking. Um, but
anyways, uh, the point is that like
there's no illicit thing within this
frame. There's no
>> He means us, by the way. Okay. Connor
just left recently. I think
>> no evidence of harassment or stalking or
swatting within this frame, but it's
kind of I don't know like um
I want to say inculcating, but I think
there's a better word. Incubating
>> kind of. Yeah, it'll be a thing where
like if you were to post something on
KF, it'll be they'll talk about it
almost immediately in the Yes. Correct.
Yes. And so they all know where they're
going and then they're talking inside
Discords and like group chats about it.
Yeah. 100%.
>> So for you there's like the the whatever
thin wall between these these
communities might as well not exist.
>> Yeah. It's not there. Yeah. It's
actually funny because people accuse me
of doing it, but for me it was the exact
opposite. And I would be happy people
did what I did. People say, "Oh, um,
some people try to run with this cute
thing." I only know about Kiw cuz
Destiny all Destiny told us to go there
to harass Anna. Have you ever heard this
claim before?
>> Of course.
>> Yeah. Just and the other uh I didn't say
that about me. That's literally the Blav
origin story. He's just talking about
the Blav origin story that Blav was a
DGER, right? And that this guy only
found out about Kiwi Farms because
Destiny pointed people to Anavor's Kiwi
Farms. I'll bring this up where they're
saying that like I drove people to Kiwi
Farms. My announcement and you go find
the clip. You should ask them for it.
They never
He's my announcement was I didn't want
any of these people around me. Actually,
I would be totally fine if JTO sent
everybody to Kiwi Farms who wanted to
like talk about me. If you just sent
them to a smaller platform, if you just
sent them to a platform with less
engagement, I would be Yeah, I know you
would, but it's not the same group of
people and you're just trying to blend
them together. Play it. But like what I
told people because there was a lot of
stuff that was being posted in Kiwi
Farms and then my chat was viewing it a
lot and then they would start talking
about it in my chat. And what I said to
my chat was, "Hey, if you want to talk
about like weird related to [__] go to
KF and talk about it. Don't do it in my
community. I don't want to see that here
ever. Period." And people just How long
did he hold on to that for? Cuz when I
joined DG, I remember with Taber, okay,
watching some anor meltdown streams and
it was way after that. It wasn't after
It was It was way after this had gotten
like outlawed. I know for a fact it was.
So, how much did you actually enforce
that? And how much did you keep that
going? Or did you just send a bunch of
people to kiwi farms, run that rule for
like two weeks, two months tops, and
then just get rid of that rule cuz
you're a [__] What is this total you're
coming up with? And then we'll morph
that into like, oh, look, he was sending
people to her. But I wasn't. I wanted it
out of my community. And the fact that
it was and I know cuz I'm not an idiot
and I'm honest about how the communities
work. He's lying transparently about how
these communities work that I watched
via Anavar's stream like a dozen times
when I first joined his community. I
don't know what the [__] he's talking
about right now. If it's on Kiwi Farms
and then it starts getting spoken about
in my chat immediately, there's always
going to be an interplay there because
they know like if I type in my chat, I
know that Kiwi Farms is watching and
that happens back and forth. Yeah.
>> The the rebuttal is that you're playing
5D chess though with that.
>> That's I don't have the only time I'm
playing 5D chess or I'm like an
enigmatic complicated figure or there
it's just cuz people just don't believe
what I'm saying at face value. And it's
like I think
>> so Anavoir was like not talked about in
your chat after that. not brought up on
your stream, not brought up in your chat
is what you're saying. It's pretty
obvious like why would I like what would
even be the 5D chess
>> the 5D chess thing
>> like I'll tell you like I'm telling you
flat like there are people I will ducks
if I have the opportunity to do is
getting posted if I get it my hands on
100% but I'm not like I don't have to
sit here and like oh well
uh that by the way that is also a call
to action right there that he's openly
doing while sitting next to Connor Hold
on hold on hold on wait wait wait let's
get Let's get a better version of this
clip going. Okay. Uh oh, chat's kind of
in the way. We don't want chat here
right now. We don't want chat here right
now. Let's uh let's make sure that we
got the uh the Valor Media Network
approved doxing. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. I Connor approve this message.
>> The 5D chess.
>> The 5D chess thing 100%. I'm telling you
flat like there are people I will ducks
if I have the opportunity to. Do is
getting posted if I get it my hands on
it 100%. But I'm not like I don't have
to sit here and like I'm not I don't
need to 5D. Let's
go. Hold up.
>> But for Anna, like I legit
>> amazing amazing stuff. And this guy
accuses me of like any of these things,
bro. What are we What are we doing here?
Wick will say this isn't a threat
somehow. Dude, I think I think Wick's
like totally that one with his
community. That'll be a tough one. Okay,
there we go. There we go. There we go.
There we go. Oh, what the [__] Get out
of here. Get out of here, little Connor.
Oh, I need to pull chat back, though.
Why is my chat not coming back? Hello.
There it is. There we go. I think I need
to make that chat smaller anyway. It's
like cutting Connor off. Chat's got to
be tiny. Tiny chat.
>> Die. What is Doobie's sin?
>> The being in the in cahoots all these
weirdo a loggers that are obsessively
>> Okay, this has to be Hold on. This has
to be where Connor breaks up that like
Doobie's just been introduced, right?
He's just been introduced to this and
he's already Destiny's like I will dox
this right now. No. By the way, Connor,
this is the really important part where
you need to ask for evidence because it
Destiny has tried to collect [__] on me
or Queen or whoever for months now,
right? There might be something he could
like weave together to say like, "Oh,
here's like why just in terms of we talk
about this guy a lot, right?" And and
and it would look good to like a cultist
type person maybe, but it's all built
post Hawk. It's all built after he
started trying to do it. So, I'd say on
the Doobie front, I don't think Destiny
has any info on Dubbie. I don't think he
has any idea what Doobie was saying. He
thought Dubbie was posting in spicy
chat. Okay, Dwey been banned from spicy
chat for like a year and a half, two
years. Okay? Like, he has no information
here. He has no proof of this. And he's
going to say, "Yeah, get me Dubbies
docs. I'll post it as soon as I can."
Because none of it is built on him
actually understanding or knowing
anything. It's just built on his Fifi.
Okay? And his Fifi are pretty hurt right
now. His Fifi are not Fifiing so good.
>> Talking about me, talking about me to
every other person and doing this weird
pressure game in the background for
every single person when he was in Wix
chat because he got blown the out by
Baby Peach debate. Um where they're
playing all these weirdo pressure games.
It's just weird. Anybody that's part of
like those communities in my mind, it's
all these weirdo pressure games of like,
"Hey Wick, you said doxers are banned.
Destiny is openly doxing. Now he's
openly threatening a community member of
with doxing, right? He says he will dox
this guy as soon as he can. Right.
That's that's not a weirdo pressure
game. That's saying, "Hey, we argue in a
community where it's like we do moral
arguments with each other." Right? We do
this all the time. You said you have a
moral aversion to doxing. You have cut
off people for things that are like doc.
Are you going to follow through on this
principle with destiny? That's not
weirdo. And he doesn't he doesn't even
have evidence of what the weirdo [__]
is.
>> Jesus. It's It's so weird that the court
keeps protecting these people's
identities. It's so weird, guys. Isn't
it It's so weird and unhinged. The
judges are so unhinged for entertaining
this protective order. The judges are so
unhinged for letting all these motions
come through.
>> The I got to got to back it up a little
bit talking about me to every other
person and doing this weird pressure
game in the background for every single
person when he was in Wix chat pain cuz
he got blown the out by Baby Peach
debate. Um where they're playing all
these weirdo pressure games. It's just
weird. Anybody that's part of like those
communities in my mind is all to me.
>> Jesus the Okay, so the pressure games do
scene their Okay. Well, and then I was
going to bring this up to you as well.
>> So, and
>> evidence. No, Conor. Connor, shouldn't
you ask for what pressure games means?
What creepy weirdo behavior means? Uh
what what proof Destiny has of these
things? Right? Shouldn't you be asking
any of these questions? Literally all
Connor is doing is he's getting enough
information so he can go, "This is what
Destiny said." And it'll be like,
"Connor, do you think that's a valid
excuse?" No, that's what Destiny said.
This is He just wants to have his new
talking points programmed in so that he
can uh so that he can go, "Well, that's
not my position. It's just Destiny's,
guys."
>> I think I brought it up to you earlier
today. So, I on our
>> Oh, you know what? We might need another
uh we need another one of these stamps,
guys. Okay. We need another stamp. We
don't just need the Valor Media Network
approval, stamp of approval from Connor.
Okay, we might need an UN America Z
Cohen Sanchez. Could we get an UN
America National Ground Game seal of
approval on these clips where Desi's
like threatening to dox random politics
streamers, politics panelists? I don't
even know if Doobie streams on his own.
>> Ironically, like I said, I'm not a
religious literalist, but I do believe
in like religious precepts. And one of
the religious precepts effectively is
like you know turning the other cheek or
the mercy sin forgiveness pipeline where
it's effectively like guilt uh it's like
sin guilt
um asking for mercy atonement
forgiveness and that cycle for the
unfamiliar is like at least within
Christianity if you commit a sin and you
feel guilty uh they correlate then you
kind of seek mercy uh from the people
that you wronged you try to atone which
means try to create some justice in the
world. Um, and then even if those people
can't forgive you, ultimately God is
supposed to forgive you if you're
serious with your atonement.
>> Okay.
>> So, Conor's been trying to shoehorn them
into this conversation. Desessie's like
he is like the the toddler with the, you
know, it's the broccoli. Okay. Connor is
like the the adult trying to feed
Destiny his broccoli and Desty's like,
"No, no, I don't want it. I don't want
to eat it. I don't want to eat it." And
it's the moral the Christian the
Christian moral ethics thing where it's
like guys it's like sin what is it
acknowledgement mercy atonement
forgiveness or something I think I think
that's it whatever it was from a stupid
>> along with turning the other cheek is
supposed to make a more
>> this is fantastic you're not Lauren
southern Connor he's not going to
pretend to be religious for you
>> may well maybe there's two huge
assumptions though one
>> is that there's some afterlife where I
get to read the rewards of that and two
is that I can infinitely tank whatever
cuz I have God on my side. So, as an
atheist, neither of those things are
very compelling to me. I don't know if
the arc of history inevitably bends
towards some positive direction. So, I
don't know if there's some moral
goodness in allowing other people to
infinitely slander you with no
>> no what theible
world
>> may well there's two huge
>> I started typing a a [__] Discord
message though. One
>> is that there's some afterlife where I
get to reap the rewards of that and two
is that I can infinitely tank whatever
cuz I've got on my side. So, as an
atheist, neither of those things are
very compelling to me. I don't know if
the arc of history inevitably bends
towards some positive direction. So, I
don't know if there's some moral
goodness in allowing other people to
infinitely slander you with no response.
>> What about reciprocity?
>> I with no response. You don't have to
respond. You could actually, by the way,
I've never said this would be bad.
Destiny could actually just look at the
content that I've done, the allegations,
and how I've covered his and he could
just respond to it. I have no problem
with that. That would be totally morally
justified. That would be good, right?
But he can't respond to it. If he could
respond to it, that would be his first
tactic. That's what's missing here is
Destiny, why don't you just respond to
what they're saying? Why don't you just
show how they're lying about you? No,
he's never attempted this. He's never
once attempted this, right? The closest
he's ever come is watching Queen's
response that he basically didn't pay
attention to. The Queenman's response to
the Willy Mac thing, right? That's the
closest he ever come. Other than that,
he's never once tried to response or
sorry, respond to the content of the
criticism. And that comes way before
trying to dox people. By the way, if he
had a real response to basically
anything I've been saying since this all
kicked off in January, he would have
done so and he wouldn't have lost
anywhere near as much of his audience.
The fact that he hasn't ever tried to
respond tangibly to the things I say is
is perfect proof that he has no
response. I fully believe Mr. president
earlier. I think when we were upstairs,
you mentioned something about the doxing
thing and you like 2 years ago you said
that this was like a line and it was
horrible. I agree 100%. I think it's
horrible. I don't think anybody should
be doing it. I'm not going to stop
though. They're not going to stop
because I like I hope that they do. Uh
his response would be that he does not
want to give you any more public
attention. That's fine. Then don't give
me public attention and don't start
trying to like dox me or other people
around me. Easy. Super easy. Just ignore
it. But if your first step to action
isn't to respond, it's just to try to
dox people, then you're obviously in the
wrong. You're just obviously in the
wrong to everybody with any sense. You
feel uncomfortable. I hope that they
don't enjoy it. I hope that it really
does worry some of them because I've had
to live with that for years. Like I
said, I got swatted when my son was
here, right? I'm outside with multiple
AR-15s pointed at me having to explain
that my son is inside my apartment with
a whole bunch of guns, but he doesn't
know how to use them and he's too scared
to come out. This is a very I'm don't
know if that footage can be foyed. These
are very stressful situations. So when
somebody tells me like, "Well, isn't
doxing them too far?" I think
>> like we've just actually completed the
uh Yeah, by the way, being swatted would
be awful, right? Why say that? Um he
wants people to realize he's a victim.
Being swatted would be awful. Was he
swatted before or after? Like I thought
I was still I thought I was still
friends with him when he got swatted
when Nathan was there. Isn't that the
This Destiny guy is cooked. I thought I
thought we were still I thought that was
in like uh December or something. Maybe
I'm wrong. Oh, it was before. Okay, so
it was before. So the things he's
blaming on me or anyone around me. Oh my
god. It was during the Trump. Oh, so
this is just total horseshit. He's like,
"Oh, I want these people to be scared
cuz I live with this." But he's he's
also blaming us for the situation he was
in before any of us were like doing this
kind of content, like talking about his
>> I think it is too far, but I'm I've been
way over that line so at this point.
Yeah, if I saw them taking a stronger
stance against it where I was like,
"Okay, like I can see like people have
Oh, so it's just a blatant lie. This is
just blatant manipulation. He's making
himself a victim for something that
happened way before. This is the not so
aerodyite playbook." Amazing. Or this
Nathan swatting happened after we just
don't know about it. I don't know. But
I'm I'm pretty sure I remembered it
happening before cuz I thought Nathan
talked about it. I thought I covered
that Nathan talked about it. Pressured
or said things in the background like,
"Oh, like do you think we should do like
like these guys or whatever?" I'm like,
"No, they're not even part of this [__]
Like, I don't care about like this stuff
um or whatever." But when it comes to
like the weird spicy chat, u justical
queman, uh Kiwi Farms, that pipeline,
and then like the and then how that
connects up to like Bad Empan and Assan,
these people are these are terrorists.
No, the connection again. Conor Connor
said it and Dest Well, if you want to
say that, you could say that. Yeah, the
connection is we think you're
disgusting. They're
uh who do I if I wanted to be a
terrorist group, who would I want to be?
I don't really want to be Hezbollah.
Although Nisrala was kind of funny
sometimes when he wasn't just a raging
anti-semite. Um I don't know. These
people are unh.
I'd say FLQ if uh if Trudeau hadn't
totally mogged them. Okay. Trudeau
hadn't totally mogged them. I'd say FLQ.
Okay.
>> Deranged. Like I have no consideration.
They're crazy.
>> The Okay. So, you said something that
was honestly I was re-watching uh the
Keles drama because it's some of Chudlo
Logic's best work.
>> Yeah.
>> And in the Keles drama, uh she talked
about how Ontario, I think it was
Ontario,
>> um somebody else.
>> Anyways, police showed up to her house.
Uh they had they had rifles and pistols
and stuff. They were outside of the
door. They asked her to come out, but
they did like the call out order where
they came out. And what you described to
me was kind of parallel where you were
saying like you had a swatting incident
where several armed law enforcement
officers not with pistols but with
rifles actually showed up to your front
door.
>> Yeah. And it's weird too. I think I was
probably more stressed than Nathan cuz I
don't like obviously if you spent any
time at the range which you have. I'm
going to be pointing a gun at you is
very weird. That's a very good
terrifying.
>> Yeah. Um and then also when you have the
multiple cops shouting I see that the
Ben is it Ben Shaver?
>> There's one of those. Yeah, for sure. I
think I think it's Daniel, but
>> Oh, Daniel Shaver. Yeah. And I'm like,
I'm going to die in the most way. So,
this is all totally like fine. You can
be scared of getting swatted. Swatting
is scary. And this is, by the way, he's
describing a real swatting. This is like
actual swatting. When they show up with
rifles and they are being told there's a
dangerous situation, they have to
proceed fast or somebody's going to get
hurt. And they don't have like like
there's a time pressure, there's a
danger pressure, right? That's actual
swatting. But then the question becomes,
did this happen before or after the
people who you're mad about a logging
you started like a logging you in some
way? Which happened first? Possible cuz
these are all shouting different things
at me. Yeah,
>> you're going to do uh like
>> Simon says execution in the hallway.
>> [__] the Vos clip. I don't think
that's horrible. Um sorry. The only
reason why I'm laughing is because I uh
yeah, I've I've been
>> I just want to say cuz when he did get
swatted while his son was there, he was
smart enough not to bring attention to
it. We only knew because
>> his son brought about brought it up in
his Discord. It's very possible
something could have happened again and
he's smart enough not to mention it,
right? And so he's going to try to
mention it but through like the past
thing.
>> Oh, maybe.
>> Who knows? I
>> I would just want I would just want
clarification cuz I I would hope since
Arerodite has done this I hope he's not
doing the same thing where he's saying
oh this is because the argument is that
because of me and Quimman like the
ramped up and we're like giving targets
to people we're coordinating with right
but it's like all of this happened
before we got involved at all before we
were doing negative content about it
while Queen was kind of doing negative
content about it. No, I agree. So,
because it happened before you guys were
involved, this is attention that he's
brought on himself a couple of times. If
it's happened recently, don't be like,
"Please make it clear. Tell me if it
happened again." Like, I feel like you
should never do that to somebody. But
you can just use the fact that it's
happened previously to be like, "This is
you, buddy. This is your
>> sure on the internet."
>> I'm just generally saying that I think
like you don't have to give me a recent
time or anything. You just say if it was
before or after.
>> But but also Yeah, you're right that it
was already a thing that was happening.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. 100%. I I need to come up with a
thing to make it swap faster. Get her a
mic. I have another mic. I just have to
set it up at some point. I'd have to go
listen also to how well it comes
through. What?
>> Okay, we're back. We're back.
>> Situation where I had a uh firearm
uh there was a firearm in an
irresponsible party's hand and they were
not friendly to me. And so yeah, that's
terrifying because you basically know
>> within a second or two uh you can get
get your life snatched out of your body.
So it's mad uncomfortable
>> on camera too.
>> Yeah.
>> The worst part is like the dying sucks.
So the worst part is knowing that these
losers are going to be like celebrating
and clapping about their streams.
>> They would they would have
>> if I get killed by the cops before gets
k by cherry. That would just be an epic
on my part. So
>> all right the we used to all be friends.
>> I also agree that would be shad. Oh,
wait. No, that would be awesome. Okay,
that's crazy.
>> What's up?
>> I literally come in here to say
something peaceful and then I got to
hear that [__] all the time. I am going
to kill you, but it's not because he
told me to.
>> Awesome. Love you, too. Anyway, we
continue.
>> Um,
okay. So, their contention is that this
is a one-way street. They're not
participating in these behaviors. You're
saying,
>> of course,
>> that
>> what you think is do you think that's
[__] or do you think I'm crazy?
>> I have no idea. And and I'm not saying
that because I'm I'm not saying that to
be cute or play both sides or whatever.
The reason why I'm saying that is
because I am very stupid in one regard.
When people say things to me, I believe
that what they're saying is what they're
thinking and it correlates with their
perception of reality.
>> Okay, hold on. This is dangerously close
to introspection and growth is we're
right there. Do not get mad. do not get
mad right now.
>> And I've had that problem the entire
time. And so when people lie to me, I'm
oftentimes the only way that I find out
that somebody is lying is if like it's
100% proven the opposite of true. And I
the funny thing is is I I don't know
about Queen can't speak for him, right?
I've had to operate this way the whole
time. When I say right, when I say and
I'm like arguing about anything to do
with Desi, I have to have like dead set
proof on these things like every time
cuz people will hold me like to the
highest bar. And then Desi says the most
brain damaged.
He just totally openly lies and nobody
checks him. It's so annoying. Okay. Oh
sh Oh sh Oh,
>> in my last video I
>> Oh,
the Destiny situation is unhinged.
He can't even He can't even escape the
destinyism in the title. Crazy. Willie
Max show 12 seconds ago. Well, we'll
have to finish the Connor thing. God,
I'm like I wish these people would shut
the up. Okay, I wish they would all shut
the [__] up so I could do other content
cuz I'm not interested in them. But
sometimes, listen, this is a good convo.
This is fun to react to. Okay.
>> I would say that uh I have talked to
Queenman or whatever. I sent him some uh
information that I felt was relevant to
the situation and he seemed to be like I
don't know uh entertaining the ideas, I
suppose.
>> But
>> yeah.
>> What do you mean by entertaining the
ideas? He's part of it. He's actively
part of it. What do you mean by
entertaining ideas?
>> Well, right. But that's the um uh
effectively entertaining the ideas that
there might be evidence between the
correlates uh between Kiwi Farms
harassers and the Discords.
>> Okay.
>> So he was saying like, "Okay, yeah, this
is a possibility. However, I need to do
research for XYZ ABC."
>> Okay. So he's just lying. He's just
saying she shouldn't play. You're saying
he's [__] lying until he knows 100%
what's going on. Yeah. He's a huge part
of it. But
>> that's okay. All right.
>> Well, that's I'm sure I'm sure I'll get
another DM where he's like, "No, I'm not
lying. Destiny is the one that's lying.
He's a [__] musician. He should kill
himself.
>> Baste,
>> right? All right. So,
>> here's like um this is like an example.
Uh if you really want later, I could
find I don't really like to show it on
stream. Um so, this was said I think
about a day after like a third fan of
mine had been um they're just doxing
random fans of mine on
>> No. Didn't they get um I'm not saying
it's related, but Tech got doxed like
two weeks after.
>> No, that's not related. I don't know
about that. Don't know about that. Don't
care about that. Don't know about that.
Don't care about that. Don't know about
that. Don't care about that. Okay.
>> But well, actually maybe but I didn't
see if it was
>> chronologically. I found it.
>> So they're literally talking like random
people. Uh
>> who's I what does random mean? When
Destiny says random, it's almost never
random. I want to know what what he
means by random here.
>> On on keeps who are my fans, right?
>> This is um I don't know if this is Coin
or Dior. I'm mixing these guys up a lot
now. But this is um No, no, wait. Just
stay over there. You just listen. Okay.
Okay. This is just to go watching one of
these fat guys watch my stream and then
I think he sees somebody on Twitter.
Just listen to the Hold on.
>> Oh, they put it all in the thing. It's
like the guy's a rage cow. He's lashing
out. He's doing any damage he possibly
can.
>> This guy's talking to me.
>> Incorrect. That's
>> go down with that ship. Be my guest. All
right. Because you Oh, I used to
respect.
>> Notice how he said that. If you want to
go down with that [__] be my guest.
That's not true, though. You don't have
the ability to go down that ship because
they will hunt you and chase you and try
to divide you and whatever, right? They
don't give you the opportunity to do
that. But yeah, go ahead. Like, bro, I
don't give a [__] who respects me on
this at all whatsoever. To me, you're
just another name in the chat. Nobody
replaced.
>> He says he doesn't give a The only
reason, by the way, why Willie Mack made
that phone call and recorded it and then
published a video about it, giving me
time to Just kidding. But the only
reason he did that, by the way, was
because Dioro I'm I'm just saying it's a
really stupid video like that. If you
really do believe this, it's really But
um the only reason Will is because Dioro
pressured him to do that. Just you know.
Um and there's Dioro's on Dior's on
stream.
>> Oh, I'm not muted. I'm not muted. I just
wanted to let that uh image speak for
itself there.
>> Saying that that he's the one who like
pushed him really hard to do that. But
okay, hold on. Listen to the
>> Oh, god damn it. So many people only
watch. I When that happened, I pulled up
the tweet of Willie saying everything
Destiny is saying here is true. The part
where it's like, okay, why would you
make that video and publish it? You can
make the video. In fact, I encourage you
to make the video and just show that you
did it. Uh just in case people, you
know, people call you out and say, "Oh,
you didn't do anything." Right? You
could keep proof of that. You could let
people know about that, but probably
like letting it putting it out
immediately, publishing it immediately
is a little silly.
>> My publish is because Doro pressured him
to do that just, you know. Um, and
there's Dor is on Dior's on stream
saying that that he's the one who like
pushed him really hard to do that. But,
okay, hold on. Listen to the
>> Are you going to go past skip past the
tablet he keeps with clips of you at the
ready?
>> Uh, no. He's You understand how much he
watches the stream, right? Like he is
always watching the stream. He is always
here. Always. I'm not shocked that he's
got a Dude, if only this guy could get
past me thinking he's like a totally
degenerate, harmful piece of [__] who
like cannot is not capable of accepting
uh or respecting other people's consent.
If if I could get past that, okay, if I
could just stop hating this guy, maybe
he could get stop maybe he could uh
channel his abilities for good. Maybe he
could be like my strongest clipper,
right? He's like right there. He could
be my strongest clipper if we just could
tweak this relationship a little bit.
>> How is anybody saying I don't respect
you? He's just being like, Destiny's a
liar. I don't want to defend this guy at
all. This guy sucks. Somebody apparently
is saying, "Nick, I don't respect you to
that."
>> So, he's talking about somebody in chat.
This is a chatter that said this. And
then this was saying,
>> "Find that person.
>> Find that person.
>> Person is not safe to be around children
or women." Okay?
>> Find that person. Mark them for the good
of society. Okay? They need they need to
be tracked right at the beginning.
>> So, he's saying this. I do mean the
alias. Like, we need to know the alias.
I don't mean doxing them,
obviously.
I'm like I'm literally just joking. But
hey, it is what it is. Jesus Christ.
What's this? Oh, don't pull that up on
stream. Disavow that. Oh, somebody
banned him already. Okay. Thank you.
Appreciate the ban. Jesus. Got you.
You're cooked. I I do like basically
laughing at like to me the funny thing
that happens recently is how like insane
some of the chatters are like how it's
very obvious when it's like one person
comes in they're like didn't he like not
know her age right the whole time but
you know if that guy if that guy got
doxed I would feel bad about that okay I
feel bad for singling him out yeah maybe
I'll I'll reflect on that you know
calling people out while it is funny.
While it is a lot of fun, I might have
to think about how to how to censor that
out for people. Okay, that's a meme. And
if you would push him, they go like,
"Oh, does something." But they're like
one of the guys that got doed on Kiwi
Farms. This was the basically exactly
what they were saying. This guy's not
safe to women or children and he works
as this job. So, we're going to email
his employer. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. He's not talking about Odish right
now, is he? No, maybe he's not. I don't
know what he's talking about. I
literally don't know what he's talking
about and we're going to try to like get
him fired from his This is the guy who
emailed me said to call the cops. So
Jessica reads his thread.
>> Wait, who is this? He's lying. I don't
know if he's not talking about Odishara.
I don't know who he's talking about,
right? Because the only person I think
he could be talking about here is
Odashara. And that's not even remotely
the story with Odashara. I have no idea
what this is.
>> That's cuz they all read him and post
about him. So he knows what he's doing.
But it's always like stuff like that.
There's like dozens of examples of like
>> dozens of examples. Show two more. He's
talking about Odashar and he's lying
about the framing. Yeah, Odashar is a
total and obviously lied about what
happened with regards to that entire
situation. And I'm I'm positive he lied
about like any letter getting sent to
him. If you don't know the story about
Odashar, this is a Destiny fan who said
that he was doxed and somebody dropped a
letter off at his house making fun of
him. Now, the things that they said to
make fun of him in that letter happened
happened to overlap one to one with what
he was really upset people in voice chat
were saying about him that he was like a
or something which I'm sorry is just
funny you okay he was very upset about
that and so he said because nobody would
ban those people for laughing at him he
started spamming fs slurs in VC and got
banned from the server right he got
timed out then he basically while he was
timed out he said I got a letter to my
house and they were saying the same
thing. So you have to stop them from
doing this and it's like okay can you
show me the letter? No, he threw it out
as soon as he got it. Okay, so he threw
out the letter as soon as he got it. I
said that was pretty crazy. Eventually
he just kept pushing. He's like I'm not
even sure. I'm like 98% sure it wasn't
even somebody from your server. And I'm
like okay I think you are just lying. I
actually just think you're lying. I
think you're making this up entirely.
That's that's the story I think he is
currently trying to recount.
deniability.
>> Yeah. Always. It's how they work. Yeah.
But this is like the goal. That's how
they do it. Yeah. So now if you're in
the future, you talk about chilling
effect. O, do I really want to say
anything bad about these guys? Like
Jesus. Like what if he calls me out and
then I'm the next person that gets doxed
on Kiwi Farms and they post my Yeah.
Would they did this happen? Hold on. He
said this happened. Now I need like any
evidence of this cuz I don't recall this
happening, right? I don't know who this
could possibly I I would need to see any
evidence of this. I hope Connor sees
evidence of it, right? I hope Connor
takes this transcript and asks for exact
receipts of the things Destiny just said
happened to show that Destiny wouldn't
just go on this stream and lie to both
Connor and his audience about what
happened. Right. He's a serial docer
himself. What the [__] Uh yeah, he is.
I'm just saying that I really hope the
chilling effect is tendency. Dude, I
just want to uh I would just like to see
Connor ask for this evidence of like the
things he said here and just make sure
it matches up to what actually happened.
So
yeah,
>> the I have a totally unproductive,
stupid idea in my brain, but at the same
time, it's like it seemed like a year
ago, two years ago, uh if we had beef,
and this is something that I respected
you for, uh effectively like having open
coms even with like really small
creators.
>> Sure.
>> So if somebody had beef, they could
basically come say it to your face. Now
though, it seems like the game is
>> I'm totally down for any of these people
to come talk to me. I literally have s I
don't want to talk to Destiny cuz he's
gross. Like I He's just gross. Okay, not
really interested in that. But
essentially everybody else I'm totally
down to talk to
>> this doc war and
um I don't know like like there there's
no treaty here.
>> Well, because um there's no diplomacy
there. There's no like like what what
how could we get and
>> we can't we can't come into a room and
say hey Stephen I think you're the
biggest piece of [__] on the [__] and
I hope you die one day and then boom
it's squashed
>> no because that's not the goal um I
don't remember we were talking about the
beginning of this at the beginning of
this conversation unironically yes that
is the goal the goal is to one of those
two things either for me to kill myself
somebody around me to kill themselves or
to destroy my career right the perfect
example of this
>> what happens if they don't get it
>> then they just then they'll try to do it
to the people around me look at how they
they spam a picto channel why do you
think it got terminated today.
>> Well, and that that's another thing,
too, is like
>> there's no evidence anywhere that we
spam reported Kyla. We don't want Kyla
gone. We literally pay our bills monthly
based on Kyla existing. I literally have
multiple multiple Okay, multiple Kyla
soundboards on my
I don't want Kyla banned from the
internet. I don't want her gone. I I
don't we don't want her gone. Been
waiting on her response. Well, she did
get terminated and I can show you guys
exactly like the evidence of that and
stuff, but I don't want her banned. Uh,
I had I'll show this tweet right now.
Um, we got accused of this like
immediately and I'll show you the
predicate upon which we're being accused
of doing this. Okay, which is uh I say
we cuz it seems like Aiden's getting
accused of it, which makes no sense, but
like dude, this is uh last night.
>> Uh, Marty Epstein, thank you for the
five gifted. Let's go. Thank you very
much. Appreciate it, buddy. All right,
this thinking monk guy comes in. Big
surprise atx. So, there's this log from
apparently um somebody in food shops
chat says, "I'm telling you, it's
Aiden's community. They have been
working on it for a while about not so
Aerodite." Right. So, this guy says
exiled Aiden Jtock at Queenman at
Nicholas at Willymack at not food shops
at the omniiberal and they're like, "Oh,
this is about Aerodite getting uh banned
or whatever, right?" as like this is
this is the level of evidence they need
to make these allegations these kinds of
allegations. No, food shops didn't tell
them that. That's just a random chatter
in food shops that said this. Okay, I
just respond like dude, why the [__]
would have we want to report such a
consistent source of content. It doesn't
make any sense. Our this entire time,
okay, we have one weapon. It's the only
weapon we're interested in using, okay?
It's our voices. That's the only weapon
we use. We just talk to people. We talk
to people. We talk about people. We
analyze content. We speak about it. It's
just a voice. That's the only thing.
That's the only blade. Okay? That's the
only blade with we engage in using.
There is nothing else. It's not even a
screenshot. It's not. It's not. Dude, we
just want the We just want to not get
lied about. Occasionally, we make some
horrendous meme videos or meme
donations. Dung devil, there's no shot
you actually fell for the troll. Fell
for the troll from the guy who pretends
to be an Indian woman all day. Kathy.
Uh, yeah. This is like like honestly
this is by the way this is one of
Destiny's top guys. The thinking monk
guy. It's one of Destiny's top guys.
Like they've gone beyond they've like
jumped the shark. They literally are
worse than like the Qinon people. Like
this is crazy that something bad happens
and they immediately I feel bad cuz I'm
not if only I was. Okay. Then we could
just say they instantly jump. Anything
bad happens. They stub their toe and
they blame the me and queen in that case
if I were right. They just blame but
they just blame me. Bro, I don't do I'm
not doing this. I don't have time to
worry about what Aerodite's doing. Yeah.
So, she got reported last night. Uh, so
she says she got reported. I I don't
know that she has any indication she was
like mass reported. She says it right.
Hey at team YouTube, my YouTube account
not so erodite seems to have been taken
down. I believe this is likely due to
mass reporting. I've already made an
appeal. Anyone willing to support and
get human eyes on it, I would appreciate
that. will update tomorrow. Totally
understand where you're coming from.
Clarify there's no amount of reporting/
flagging that can enforce our policies
on content if we don't find any v
violations on it. We understand how
important this is to you. Since you've
already submitted an appeal, we
recommend waiting for an update from our
policy team. Appreciate your patience in
the meantime. Should you respond to this
at all? Uh, somebody else asked
something else. Oh, there's something
else that happened here. I think she
talked more about it cuz I think there's
another post. Here we go. Hey, at team
YouTube, thanks for the reply. My 55K
sub channel ran three years with zero
strikes. On August 26th to 27th, two old
videos were removed. Then my whole
channel was terminated before I even had
a chance to review them. Appeal was
autorejected. My appeal of my account
removal was denied within minutes of it
being made. Can you please escalate
escalate for a manual review? Um,
I'll be honest. This is the place I'm
in.
Unlucky. Uh, maybe if she finds maybe if
she figures something out, she can let
me know what happened. Okay. How she got
out of it. This is the place I'm in. I
go to I go to like appeal my and it's
auto. It's algorithmically denied,
right? Like insta algorithmically
denied. You previously received a
warning for your content. We're not
we're not giving you a strike this time,
but we removed the content from YouTube.
None in my files. Unclear what this
references. Uh you can see an example
around 7 seconds. We're not giving you a
strike at this time. Was August 27th,
August 26th, August 27th.
and then a termination. August 31st,
1:20 a.m. August 31st, 2:58 a.m. We've
reviewed the appeal for the following.
Uh, confirmed it violates our hate
speech policy. Pay attention on these
dates. It wasn't overnight. What? Well,
there's a multiple days here. I don't
know what you mean by not overnight. Uh,
let's see here. My appeal not accepted.
Totally hear concern. Mind following us
so we can continue via DM followed. the
next steps bring to this channel
following to find out if YouTube does
the right thing that my channel was even
older. Also had no strikes and was also
removed for no reason. It's like you've
already appealed and received an email
outlining the final decision. We know it
wasn't the outcome you're hoping for,
but there's nothing more we can do. This
dude, the bots, the bots are so crazy.
It's just all AI. She had time to
respond. She did have time to respond. I
just have no idea what other content was
there and I don't know how she would
respond necessarily. Right. This hate
speech policy, hate speech policy.
more hate speech policy.
Turns out, okay, it's more than just the
Democrats who don't like people saying
sorry.
How up would it be if it was those
videos where she calls herself a and she
says she's a part of the cohort. Dude,
that'd be crazy. That would be insane,
right?
Oh, that would be I don't think that
happened. And honestly, I hope she gets
her channel back. It's It's really
stressful when you're like making a
living this way and this like gets taken
away from you like instantly, right?
with like not a lot of warning in her
case. No warning in my case, but yeah,
nobody reported her. Nobody reported
her. Um, I don't celebrate her getting
taken down. I think some people in my
community might dislike her enough to
celebrate it getting taken down. Uh, I
totally dis like I I totally disagree
with that. I don't even have to disavow
it. I disagree with that, but like I
don't know if I'm supposed to moderate
that. So, Kyla deals with like red pill
content and stuff that I'm sure that if
the other person talking was getting
reported could be a terms of service
violation, but I don't think Kyla's ever
done a terms of service violation
herself.
>> Sure. You know, you can find logs in all
the big Discords, Justicles, um, and
Spicy Chat where people are celebrating
that her channel got banned. They're
like, "Yes, we
>> Oh, that would be really bad. Could you
imagine if I controlled a channel where
people celebrated Kyla Kyla's channel
getting banned?
>> Got him.
>> We got him.
>> Um, I don't know if we got him. I check,
but yeah.
>> Oh, we got them. Oh, wait. Hold on.
Wait.
I don't think this is precisely what was
said. I think somebody sent me the log
specifically. The response is let's go,
which is not a we got them. It's a let's
go that happened in my channel. There
was only one There was only one message
celebrating and it was you. You're an
that does not mean anybody did this or
wanted this to happen, right? I don't
think celebrating means we did it or
wanted it to happen, right? Or if it
does, then I got some bad news for
Destiny. Okay, he's he's a real [__]
for this. Okay, this this thread is JTO
was banned on YouTube. Community
guideline violation. And who is here?
here. Uh, who's here celebrating it? Of
course. Oh god, what happened? Can I Can
I get the spot? Okay. Who is here
celebrating it? Of course. Haha. Casey
Tron and Jtock back toback. This is my
finest day. I think this is a packwatch
gift. Okay. Porth thought alt learning
from Tom. I see. I will never use alts.
That being said, haha, Casey Tron and
Jtock back to back. This is my finest
day. That's his employee on one of his
platforms when I got banned. Which, by
the way, that's annoying. But I didn't
ask for him to get removed for that. I
didn't even ask for anything to happen
because of that. What am I supposed to
get mad that people don't like me?
Imagine being that thin skinned. But
like apparently, you know, anybody
celebrating this, that's proof that we
wanted it to happen or we we made it
happen. That seems like complete like
the celebrated. I mean I Yeah, I get
lost.
>> If they said if they said we got him,
then I would be snatched.
>> Terminated is banning YouTube pretty
sure. Let's go like like this. Do you
notice Connor how that's like literally
not at all what happened there? Not what
was said.
>> Do you notice that? Like how are people
dude I keep saying how are people not
embarrassed by this? But if you just
look at the concurrent viewership for
the past couple days, I feel like people
are starting to get embarrassed by this.
No, I mean people are starting to get
embarrassed. They're starting to be like
a h this is kind of like garbage. I'm
I'm out. Yeah. I mean, I could ask for
more logs from shots, but yeah, they
celebrate this and they all do it. Yeah.
>> Uh, do I have my own logs? Should I pull
up my logs? Because I think I literally
said in the chat like, "Yeah, I I'm
upset this happened." Like, I I don't
like that that happened. Right.
>> Okay. So, go ahead.
>> No, no, no, no. Um, I
>> Oh, this guy right here, food stamps
played a clip where the epsler can be
heard multiple times. Is that to on
YouTube? They do, but it'll always be
stuff like this where cuz then I don't
know if that's for my community.
>> I was watching that. I basically don't I
just don't really I'm not a reporting
kind of person in general is up. But
>> but even more what because I guess like
the you doing this when you debate like
justical and you ask questions about
this. He'll what he'll sell what he'll
tell you is he'll go oh really show me
in our chat where we said report this
person. Show me you'll no I'll say show
me the evidence you have for why you
believe this. He's just lying. What
evidence do you have to believe this?
I'm not saying you have to show me a
precise thing. He did this to Pisco as
well. Remember when he gaslit Pisco and
was like, "You asked me for a precise
clip." No, I'm saying why do you believe
this? Can you just show me why you
believe this at all? Right. Just show me
why you believe it. But he did it Pisco,
too. He just lied about like how
specific people are asking um how
specific of evidence people are asking
for. I'm literally just trying to have a
conversation with a lot of people who
think this cuz I know I'm in the right.
If I'm just n nice and understanding
with people, I know I'm in the right. I
know they'll see it. I know they'll
understand. Doesn't he also do this
exact same stuff but more explicit when
he asked for clips to get you banned?
Yep. 100% he did that. Yep. Would he not
ask for timestamps precisely for my to
get me banned? I'm pretty confident he
did. Yes. Then he goes to his platforms
which are far larger and tries to get me
banned from you'll never find it and
then you auto lose on all the debates
and that's why people get like gassed on
it.
>> Also appeal to how bad these people are.
So, for instance, they could probably do
this with me quite simply.
>> Um, if food chops was unrepentant
about a moral issue on which we
disagree, they would be like, "Oh, well,
doesn't she do this or aren't you happy
that she's banned?"
>> You know, so so they would appeal to my
>> Sure. Maybe eventually. Yeah. Or if you
you can't defend principally any concept
because they'll accuse you of supporting
the worst of the accusations.
>> Yeah. What the happened to, by the way,
sorry, this is just like a frustrating
thing. What happened to I have my morals
that I live by and you have your morals
that you live by
and if we share a political project or
share a project, we can work on the
shared vision of the project, but you
live by your morals, I live by my
morals. What the [__] happened to that?
Cuz I thought
>> that's not you're just under Okay, so
Andrew Tate being a part of the
conservative movement is a huge positive
then. So, as long as we're clear, that's
fine. I thought I thought the whole
point was you have certain morals that
like are red lines for you. I thought he
outlined this and one of his red lines
was doxing like two years ago. God,
that's
>> how adult human beings operate.
>> You're you're playing a different game.
This is what people I've said this to
Democrats versus Republicans. You're
just you have to understand you're
playing a different game.
>> What game am I playing and what game are
they playing?
>> All he has to say is why his morals
change. But when he says, "Oh, my morals
change." He's like he's going I'm doing
a pragmatic analysis that's like, "Well,
we could do more good with Destiny."
which is wrong. By the way, this is an
incorrect analysis, but he's doing that
pragmatic analysis. And he's uh he's
come to the conclusion that
>> actually if I just don't enforce my
morals, that's better for the world.
Lots of people do that. Rarely works.
Okay? Rarely works. Usually, you just
end up getting chewed up and spit up by
some machine that's convincing you it
was okay to give your morals up in the
first place. You're playing some kind of
politics or whatever game and they're
playing like the social pressure game.
It's a different thing. They have
different goals. It's like if we were to
argue over and over again like what the
best car is and you want to win a race
and I just like the color blue.
Sometimes we might agree if they're
really fast blue cars, but other times
I'm going to choose like the Prius
because it's blue and I like it and
you're going to be scratching your head
trying to figure out what the [__] is
going on. This is what I was saying in
the beginning where like some criticism
you said, "How can we hold our own to
account without, you know, uh
>> without burning the bridges?"
>> Yeah. And it's and I said this very
easy. You just tell people, "Hey, you
[__] up. Don't [__] up again. Like
we'll figure it out." Or if you're going
to keep [__] up, you know, we cut
ties or whatever. But these people, you
can tell that's not the goal of any of
this, right? The goal is not to hold
people accountable. By the way, Connor,
I still think Connor believes that
doxing is bad. He could engage in this
very easily. Hey, Destiny, if you dox
Doobie, I'm walking, right? He could he
could lay that out. If you dox Doobie
for nothing other than like basically
disagreeing with you, think you're a
piece of I'm done. Right? If he wanted
to actually enforce his morals here, if
he wanted to do what Destiny's saying,
right? The issue is it doesn't matter
what kind of piece of [__] Destiny is.
These people all make excuses for it all
the time. Their spines are flexible and
their sp their spines are flexible
because they're going to make money off
of it. I I understand like I know where
they're coming from. I just it it feels
like uh if I'm not getting the money, I
should at least get to call it out,
right? If I'm not getting the money from
that, I should get to call it out. Come
on. The goal is not to like do something
righteous or good or virtuous. I said
that as much when I was responding to
Ethan about Willie. Like if Willie would
have told me privately, he's like, "Hey,
you told me be really uncomfortable.
Like I'm like even or even if he didn't
tell me to be depressed like I had to
call somebody at the FBI like say some
[__] I'd be like I got it. That's fine.
I understand that. But like there's a
difference between that and like I what
what
so is not actually mad about the FBI
getting called. He's mad about Willie
publicizing it. And he I feel like he's
not even mad about Willie publicizing it
from the angle that it up the
investigation cuz obviously telling him
privately would the investigation up.
He's mad that Willie gave him the
ability for other people to like
criticize Destiny on the things he told
Willie. That's transparent, isn't it?
That like you still lose the
investigation. You still harm the
investigation if he tells Destiny,
right? In private. But he's like, I
wouldn't even be mad at you if you just
told me in private, will he? Isn't that
a little child between friends? Isn't
that something that could stay between
friends, Willie? Come on, man. Come on,
Willie.
>> Like, hold on. Okay. Detective. Like
that's this is that's you're playing a
totally different game at that point,
right? You and that's what I'm saying is
that so you're asking like well how can
we have these conversations? You can't
they're after something fundamentally
different. They're not looking for
reform or you you you guys all catch
that, right? That he's just made it very
clear that his actual problem with
Willie is that Willie like publicized
this not it's not from the compromises
the investigation angle. It's published
it to hurt Desty's reputation. That's
that's the actual transgression here.
That's nuts to just come out and say
that directly
>> or to build like some coalition
politically. They're just want to have
like a social game.
>> Am I Well, I I think the answer I think
I have to go down with my own ship
though. I I think I'm
>> You know, uh Quimman was kind of
laughing about this. He's like uh and
I'll use a direct quote. He was like,
"Oh, Connor was our inside guy with the
PV drama." You know, he kept telling us
things that we shouldn't know. And I was
thinking to myself like during that it's
like no I was telling you the truth like
I wasn't you know like like yeah I have
a side and I care about my side
>> but in so far as I can possibly tell the
truth if you ask me a question I'm going
to tell the truth.
>> Sure.
>> Do you know what those guys say about PV
now though?
>> What?
>> Like Queen just
>> Well, isn't it like the
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is he
going to say some insane about what I
think about PV that's not even remotely
true? You want to know something funny?
Okay, you want to know something really
funny? When I was talking to Wick and
Counterpoints, they're both on my
stream. I'll have to go back and check
the logs and try to line them up with
the date. You know who was DMing me
questions for Wick to show that Wick was
being kind of about the PV stuff? It was
Destiny. Destiny was sending me
questions through DMs of like, "Ask Wick
this next. Ask try to ask Wick this."
Now, the funny thing was I asked Wick
those questions and then Destiny jumped
on to defend Wick from those questions
or like some in some downstream
conversation like jumped on to start
protecting Wick. It was the weirdest
thing I've ever like seen. It was very
bizarre. It was just it was very weird,
which is fine. Like I I didn't really
care, but it was just it was interesting
to me that that's But like he had he had
a lot of reservations about PV. I think
he had a lot of reservations about PV
and now he's like, "Oh, can do you know
what just say about PV now?" I would
love to hear this cuz I have a feeling
based on what he said that where I agree
with Hassan entirely um on the chorus
stuff. I just assume he has no idea what
I actually think.
>> Dark money preview to the Taylor the
Ren. Jessica literally comparing the
chorus tenant media and every to
I've actually I think I said the tenant
stuff is like not a good comparison cuz
people will just go that it was foreign
money so it's automatically bad
>> right
>> but the in terms of the funding and how
it was like being spent yeah the the
carry committee setup is like yeah it's
like pretty close
I by the way don't think either of those
things are inherently evil I totally
disagree with that framing that other
people do. So like these are not people
who have
>> well can can somebody like so so I had
this conversation with Becket a while
ago and and I had this conversation with
Becket last last night not specifically
about PV but I had a conversation with
them
>> and his point with the PV thing was if
it's not disclosed then you don't
understand people's biases and so they
can be acting like they're they're
acting from like a an integrated
principled position but they're biased
by money which is why you should
disclose where your money comes from.
>> Come on.
>> Is this Dude, I
>> You hear me? Yes or no? Okay, so we
>> They don't even edit this out. This was
only a couple hours ago. There's no time
to edit it out.
>> So, I probably got like another 20
minutes.
>> Okay. Okay. Go ahead.
>> Um, so what I was saying was uh the
politics game. Um I don't know if people
caught that but effectively like
um Queman said like oh he was our inside
man he was telling us secrets we weren't
supposed to know any of that and all
that kind of stuff but it was like no I
was just telling you the truth as I
understood it and also if you have like
let I'm working for an institution right
but let's say that and that institution
is paying me but we are aligned on goals
as far as what we want to achieve in the
world
>> what's the problem
>> and I think that this It's the heart of
the Taylor the Rens drama where
realistically like people don't believe
me. They genuinely just don't believe
me. A Democratic organization named
Pavey reached out to me. They said,
"Hey, you're in the Twitch and YouTube
politics scene. We need uh a Republican
to be a part of our organization. We see
I think this is intentional for Pavey. I
think to claim you're nonpartisan, you
do need like some Republican point of
view like to do the because I think to
have this exact designation, you need to
be nonpartisan like and possibly some
form of nonpolitical,
right? I So when people are like, well,
look, we have somebody who doesn't agree
with the Democrats. We're not Democrat.
It's like, dude, you are so full of
which again, I just don't like being
lied to. Just don't tell me you're not
partisan. Just don't tell me that. Just
just you don't have to make a different
video that I cannot watch where I don't
have to watch you lie. Don't treat me
like a lie to me. Okay.
>> I know that you think that Trump is
[__] bad and going to be a disaster
for this country. Would you want to work
together in order to help bring alt
media into real world politics and god
>> and do you want to help? Shut up.
>> No, you're describing lobbying,
>> I guess. So, they're just as what you're
saying because the argument that I make
a lot. people have this understanding
that lobbying is this nefarious thing
where these buy but in reality people
just support people and provide
epistemic resources to people who
already agree with them basically like
Apac is not turning people into Israel
supporters they just find people that
they feel like supports Israel and then
they throw some money at their campaign
>> well and not just that I'm sure that
they give them like talking points
>> that's not all that it is though it the
issue is okay you support Israel Apac
backs you commits an atrocity
now You're sitting there, oh, I kind of
won my last election based off of Apac
being like 50% of my funding. Am I going
to be 100% honest in my criticisms of
Israel now that I've gotten that money?
I did agree with them, but they've
pushed it a little further, right? They
pushed they've they've become a little
less supportable. And maybe am I going
to speak my conscience or am I going to,
you know, do the calculation that Connor
did and say, I could do more good in the
world if I keep my seat and I can
actually have a finger here and I'm I'm
not as compromised as some of the other
people here, right?
>> Some resources. Yeah. Hey, people are
are coming at you for like this stuff,
but like this is what we would say about
>> you used a 14 letter word, so that's
okay. I do that sometimes. The Okay, so
so the point is like
>> this cuts to the heart of the Taylor
Ren's drama where you could argue
something about disclosure. You could
argue something about transparency or
some. What the is the problem with
Democrats incubating Democratic or
liberal creators to spread a Democratic
or liberal message in this political
atmosphere. And not just that, half
these people who we're talking about in
the drama and commentary space.
>> Literally no problem with this
whatsoever. As I've stated like a
thousand times,
just don't like being lied to. They
identify as either liberals or
progressives.
Who? This is They're just doing the
Hassan thing. Why are you guys getting
so mad at me? I just support free
healthcare. I just want universal
healthcare. Why are you getting so mad
at me? It's cuz of the other you're
lying about. Sorry, Ogre Boy. I'm sorry
you had to hear that, Ogre Boy. Okay. I
I'm sorry you had to hear that. But yes.
Yeah, I know. Willie Mack dropped a new
video. We'll probably check it out. Uh
guys, don't forget if you want the
stream to go for longer, we are two subs
away from another hour on the stream.
All right, two subs away from another
hour. I guess you just don't want to
help Democrats win. It's like, yeah, I
just don't want to. You're just lying.
By the way, like don't don't slide to
Taylor Loren's and just point out the
actual problems with the article. She
was too hyperbolic in like these two
places. You don't have to you don't have
to lie about her. You don't have to say
she's a hypocrite cuz she took dark
money with no evidence. You don't have
to do any of that. You don't have to
tell me that your your chorus media
group has no alignment at all with the
Democratic party. You don't have to tell
me that. Just shut the [__] up. Don't
lie to me. That's all I want. Just don't
lie to me.
It's like so crazy. But instead, when I
when I say I just don't want to be lied
to, they're like, "Oh, so you just you
just don't want Democrats to win. You
just want like a third term of Trump, I
guess."
>> Yeah. Give me a second. I'm
>> talking about in the drama and
commentary space. They identify as
either liberals or progressives.
>> They identify as being on the left. What
the is your Why is this a crabs in a
bucket situation? So there's
>> slicing the legs out of your the people
who are propagandizing on your behalf.
>> So we don't have time to go into this
right now. We don't. We can in the
future though. Maybe I won't future
debates. There's a lot of things going
on here that I've realized now,
especially over the past few days. One,
the whole concept of dark money is
actually [__] stupid. There's no such
thing as dark money unless you literally
No, actually there's no such thing as
dark money.
>> I mean, Rathon sending me money in an
offshore bank account. I think that's
dark money. But that doesn't even make
sense because they would never send you
that money unless you knew that they
were sending you that money.
>> I know. I'm
>> Yeah. Well, no, no, but people actually
make that argument, right?
>> And also, Rathon, you can send me money.
>> Yeah. So, one, I actually don't even
believe in dark money as a concept now.
Um, and I think that it's been a weird
bastardization of the problems with
Citizens United. People keep
hyperfixating on this concept that
Citizens United was bad because of like
dark money, dark money, dark money. [__]
dark money. Who cares about dark money?
The problem is because of the way the
501c4s work and these 5287s work. I
think 527 530. The problem is that you
can put an unlimited amount of money
towards certain issues. And they you're
not supposed to be for a politician, but
they basically are. That's the issue. It
wouldn't matter if Jeff Bezos could give
$5,000 of dark money because that's the
FEC limit to some campaign. The issue is
when he can spend $50 million without
any This is literally the precise
problem that we have. This is literally
like precisely he's describing the exact
issue when we say PV and and chorus
overlap. It's because of the same
problem with not knowing the source of
the money or how much is there or what
the it's like all of the same things.
There's so many things that are
overlapping here. I don'tbody knowing on
some issue with that. The big issue with
super PACs is the unlimited per
individual spending. That's the big
deal. Number one. So or kind of tied in
number. So this concept of dark money is
stupid in my opinion. No, not in my
opinion. It's stupid because the big
criticism that Taylor has is these guys
are taking money from dark money does
not refer to just so we're clear, dark
money does not refer to whether or not
they disclose that they're getting paid.
That's not what dark money means. Morris
and one of their donors is um what is it
the 1630 fund? Yep.
>> How the is that dark money? Because it's
get they're getting paid by chorus to do
a job and one of course or maybe chorus
person
because the 1630 fund is a dark money
fund. It's a I assume a 501c4, right? Or
wait, did I say 1630? Yeah, 1630 fund.
It might not be a 501c4. I actually
don't know. It might not be. It is
literally a 501c4.
I I feel like I'm being gaslit.
>> There's 1630. Where's the dark money? Is
it Do I have to know every single person
that comes into 1630? Let's say that I
wanted to sponsor you if I don't
publicly disclose all of my income
sources. Is me paying you? Is that dark
money? 16:30 is literally
>> not if it's on my taxes.
>> That's it's so this whole dark money
concept is stupid as
>> the Okay. the impropriety or the opaque
nature of the allegations is the fact
that allegedly which by the way I
haven't seen like within the contract
where it says this
>> but they said uh allegedly that the
there's four funders who provided 70% of
the funding of the 1630 whatever thing
>> and they were saying that as chorus
creators
>> don't mention chorus unless you mention
us in this specific regard
and do not talk about our funders. Now,
that's all he hearsay.
>> I would be careful. Yeah, because
Taylor's lies at least 10 plus times in
that article.
>> But like,
>> okay, name the lies. Where are the lies
>> there? So, people keep sending me
>> there are there are I mean, I would call
it stretching, right? It's like
narrativeizing.
I wouldn't say there's 10 out I don't I
don't think it's possible that there are
10 outright lies in that article. the
clip of the article that says that, but
they don't say, "We have a copy of a
Skype call."
>> Well, she says she has copies of today,
but she doesn't say, "We have a copy of
the contract."
>> Yeah, she has said that.
>> Well,
why won't he say the actual allegation?
Don't trust Wired because they lie. Do
not trust Wired because they lie is what
he needs to be saying. It's not saying
Taylor Loren reviewed these contracts
and this is what happened. It says the
Wired editorial staff reviewed these
contracts, right? So, accuse the
publication of publishing lies. Do not
accuse Taylor Loren of lying. Do not try
to use Taylor Lorenz's uh reputation
because it's not her reputation that's
going to be on the line if it if we find
out that Wire didn't actually vet these
contracts.
>> Well, but then show me in the contract
saying that we can't talk about
>> that because she's lying.
>> Well, then at that point, I would say
her and [__] everybody who's fallen for
it. on top of that, dude.
>> So again, I I know that Destiny's not
dumb enough to have not understood what
it means when wired when it says wired
editorial staff based on contracts
reviewed by the wired editorial staff or
whatever the he knows exactly what it
means, right? Why is Connor Why is
Connor so dumb?
God, he's like the one person who will
actually like talk to Destiny in any
sort of negative way. Listen, this is
the best they can do. Okay, this is the
least sick ofantic person. He's still a
massive sickopant, but why does he have
to be so dumb, too? He's like right
there. He could just ask like one more
question. It' be so easy.
>> I'm sorry if you're getting about it,
but like we are projected to kill 14
million people over the next 5 years
through incompetence by slashing PEPAR
and slashing US ID. And by the way, the
projections could be off by 90% and we
would still kill 1.5 million people
through incompetence through preventable
disease.
>> Yeah,
>> that's [__] up by itself.
>> I agree.
>> Add another 20 crimes of Trump. Why the
do we give a [__] about Democrats
working with Democrats in order to
forward Democrat causes?
>> Wait, why?
>> Why?
>> Why do people care? No, no, no. Why do
people care?
>> Okay, give me 5 seconds. I think the
leftists and the progressives want to
bully the liberals so they can take a
larger market share of the Democratic
party.
>> Yes. So then what you have to understand
is none of
>> all I think we all agree that some
amount of Taylor Lorenz's uh what would
you call it? um motivation was that I'm
mad that this group is going to issue
like some of the more progressive people
that I like. I'm kind of annoyed about
it. Some amount of this was driven by
that. Okay, you can tell from her Glenn
Greenwald interview that some amount of
her motivation for this article was
because of that. Okay, that doesn't mean
you get to lie about her. That doesn't
mean you get to lie to me. That doesn't
mean you get to lie to the people who
like follow you, who follow your
creators. Stop lying. of this is about
making Democrats stronger. None of this
is about giving good or transparency.
None. Because Taylor Lens and all these
people accept dark money too. If if
that's how you define it, 100
does. Okay. Um his his thread literally
proved nothing. It's just garbled
garbage. Is the thread he did total. Uh
I'm starting to think that not unlike
Willy Mack, did Destiny have like a
ghostriter before? Cuz I swear to God,
since the allegations came out, he's
gotten dumber. And I'm starting to think
he might have actually had a ghostriter
before because he does that whole thread
where he shows that in 2022, I think the
Omdar Network Services LLC accepted
$45,000 from the 1630 fund. And that LLC
doesn't work back up into the Omdar
Group and down to the Journalist Without
Borders, whatever the that program is
called, right? Journalism residence
program. and Omidar came out and said no
part of the 1630 fund has ever touched
that money right till Lorenz is
objectively not taking that dark money
but they don't deal with reality they
just are good with lying I don't know
why and then because she's accepted
money from that Ahmed yeah whatever fund
which funds itself also with a hybrid
structure and a 501c4 which is dark
money that's why she considers it dark
money because a 1630 fund is the same
thing right so it's not about any of
that it's just about destroying
it's just about destroying people who
are part of the Democratic party It's
>> uh they might be a 501c4 and they might
fund themselves the same way. Uh they're
allowed to disclose if they want to,
right? I think I would just love to see
where is the where is the Omidar funds
coming from cuz if if she's getting it
from a 501c4 and the funding is
non-transparent, then I would say it's
dark money. But I've not seen that
argument. This not argument he made or
wasn't the argument he made. It's a
501c3, not a 501c4.
Okay. Can you hide the funders with a
501c3 in the same way? Because I
So,
hold on. C3s do not have to disclose. I
know Midar is literally the name of the
billionaire. That's what I said. 501c3s
have to disclose. C4s don't have to
disclose. C3s I thought do have to
disclose. So, is he just lying here
blatantly? Okay. Well, cool. When
criticizes me, is not trying to like
make me a better person or have me held
accountable or whatever. He just wants
to destroy me and my career, right?
>> I'm just sitting here calmly analyzing
how he's making things up
>> because he hates Taylor Loren's.
How about we just Google it? Well, I
don't really have to Google it. That was
already my understanding.
Media Network has to publicly file with
the IRS. GG. I I'm sorry. I'm just
sitting here and like I'm just like I
just like knowing the truth on things.
I even said, "Oh, if they are a 501c4,
they fund themselves the same way and
they're a 501c4 and that 501c4 feeds
down into the journalist program that
she's in, then you can make that
argument." I literally said I just lay
it out conditionally.
>> Better person
>> when um better than him. Yeah. But I
mean like I'm also like 200 lb lighter.
But like and then when Trump or when any
of the Republicans are criticizing
people on the
>> It's cuz he's like 4 foot five. He's 200
lb lighter than the average person.
>> Left, right? They're not trying to make
them.
>> Okay.
Uh, listen. I I think the face reveal is
coming soon. Okay. We'll we'll see
better. When somebody says Gavin Newsome
shouldn't be tweeting like that, it's
very unbecoming. Do they want him to be
a better governor? No, they're asking.
>> No, they want him to stop tweeting.
>> Yeah, because they're holding because
he's only going to be Trump, right? So,
one of the things you have to be mindful
of, I think, is where the criticism
comes from because that'll tell you what
it's supposed to do. Taylor Lorent in
her article. I would argue that the way
that she writes as a form of doxing
because when she does articles and you
should go back and reread it or read it
if you haven't. She is very big on
naming everybody that she can.
>> Oh yeah. First name, last name, city
>> and well not even maybe city but she'll
name the people and their socials so
that you can punish them and hold them
accountable. Okay. Uh, listen, I could
probably go along with some form of this
argument that Keller Ren, I wouldn't be
shocked if when she is covering people
from a negative lens that she could name
things where if she doesn't like people,
she will give more information out than
she has to. I think that could be true.
I think there's probably an argument for
like what information needs to be
disclosed based on a public interest. I
would need to see an example of that. I
don't trust Destiny to to lay that out
really, but I could see that being true.
I think based on her doxing the uh what
is it libs of Tik Tok I can see that
probably being true. No I sorry with
this allegation I would give charity to
this allegation in in just in the form
of I think there's probably an
allegation here that she goes beyond
just the public interest in revealing
information that if it's somebody bad
she'll reveal more information than she
has to so that she she so that she can
be um like punitive to those people. I
think so. I think I've heard about this
in the past. I think this is sort of the
veiled justification she used to dox
libs of Tik Tok, right? So like I do
think I know about that.
And yeah, I have criticism for that. I'm
not a huge fan of that. Hold on. No,
you're supposed to blindly support Loren
to despite to spite Destiny. I just
don't like the lies. The lies about her
are just goofy. They make you look
stupid. Anyway,
so if you read her article, that um
chorus article, it was a hit piece 100%.
Every claim was negative. There was
nothing positive about it. Basically,
every major claim was either incorrect
or was just inconsequential, was just
stupid, right? But that's not true
either. And there were obviously not
being able to disclose this is kind of
bad. Seems kind of bad. A lot of the
rolling their network into yours is like
kind of parasitic. I I don't like it as
much. Maybe parasite is not the right
word because they're you're paying them,
but like uh I just I'm not a fan of
like, oh, we need all of your contacts
with these people that you talk to. Not
a huge fan. Okay.
>> Numerous. There were at least five huge
contradictions of the article. I went
there to run it on. Also the her
prescription
>> is he just going to uh I might have to
go watch his on it at some point and see
if I can find his the big contradictions
that he has laid out
>> at the end wasn't um we just think it
would be good of course publish the
contracts or we think it would be good
for they said that at the end they
quoted that v Safar whatever who said I
think that it would just be better to
donate to creators directly whatever
stupid statement what the does that mean
and then the
>> I mean I agree you should super chat and
then also going back to the third point
I was going to say I had one Two, three.
Speaking of donating to creators
directly, guys, we're one sub away from
another hour. Uh, if we can get 10 subs,
I'll add two more hours. Okay, 10 subs,
two more hours. We got to get it before
the uh before the 30 minutes, before 15
minutes have gone by. If we get 10 subs,
we'll do two more hours.
>> That'll be the Willy Mac video, and
it'll be something else. We'll see what
else we're going to do.
>> One was um uh cuz it was like the Stark
money. I don't even think it's real.
Doesn't matter. Whatever. um was why do
people pretend like being funded by an
organ?
>> There's one placebo 98. Thank you very
much.
>> Makes you more dependent on them or it
makes you more susceptible to some kind
of marketing ploy than audience capture
because I would argue to some extent
independent funding I think even you
maybe realize this independent funding
can keep you more uh independent than
audience capture. Audience capture can
keep you incredibly locked in on certain
topics or certain political opinions.
>> Uh, wow. Wow. Shsky, thank you for the
five. Let's go. That's six. We need four
more, guys. Four more in the next what,
15 minutes and we'll do two more hours.
Okay.
>> And by the way, like some people
disagree.
>> There's a big five right away. Oh my
god.
>> Oh my god. French toast Mafia. Thank you
for the five. And Shulk
Shulk, thank you for the gifted sub.
Appreciate you. Let's go, guys. That's
going to be all of the time for the rest
of the stream. We can just end all the
timers and stuff. We've got the full
eight hours. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's go. All right. All right.
>> With me or
>> um Oh, he's saying that like audience
capture. Yeah, audience capture could be
bad. Sure, audience capture could be
bad. The issue with Do you see the Bret
Cooper? The Bret Cooper video seems to
be mostly about uh his his relationship
with Nathan. I don't really want to go
through it. I saw a little bit of it. Uh
it's funny that it's getting talked, but
I just I try not to focus on that. You
know, little snide comment here or there
is the deepest we want to go in that
topic. Um shake shake. Okay. Okay. So,
here's the difference. Okay. Yeah.
$8,000 a month. As you become more
dependent on that specific funding
source, you become more likely to
compromise for that specific funding
source. It's already difficult when you
have an oiler who's doing like 10% or
20% of your like monthly budget or your
monthly income. Okay, that's already
difficult to like say you would ban them
if they're doing bad [__] right?
Obviously, the level of funding $8,000 a
month, that's crazy for most creators,
especially like Tik Tok creators. Okay.
Yeah. Audience, you can have audience
capture. You can get pulled in the
direction by audience capture. That's
for sure. If I wanted to really control
a bunch of creators, right, I feel like
audience capture and just individual
donations would be a better way to do it
if you had a lot of uh resources to do
that, right? But man, I don't know. I
don't know that you could really compare
it in the same way with no other
information
>> than audience capture. Audience capture
can keep you incredibly locked in on
certain topics or political opinions.
>> I see. And and by the way, like some
people disagree with me or whatever, but
I I think that you can only there's half
a dozen creators who are like uh Trump
apologists.
>> I think that if you look at their
principles from 10 years ago, the only
way that they you can arrive at who they
are now,
>> Connor, for the love of God, Connor,
>> please,
please don't say some that absolutely
applies to you. Please don't say some
that applies to you in the most haunting
of ways. Please, for the love of God,
Connor, do not look at the ghost of
Christmas future right now, Connor.
Please,
>> through audience capture, the only way
that they you can arrive at who they are
now is through audience capture.
>> 100%. You and I have one mutual friend.
>> Which one?
>> Who had that issue of locked in audience
capture stuff? I don't think they do
content anymore. I think they just
released a book.
>> Who the are we talking about? Sorry, I'm
being silent because Connor apparently
doesn't understand that Lauren
Southern's basically like one of like
four mutuals they have. I I don't even
know, dude. I don't even know, man.
>> Not D Laguna.
>> I think she just released a book.
>> Wait, is it Day Laguna? Who the [__]
>> No, he doesn't know. He literally
doesn't know.
>> Tell me about the rabbits again,
Stephen. Tell me about the farm. Tell me
about the farm, Stephen. Will there be
bunnies, Stephen? Jesus Christ. But
yeah, like my good friend LS.
>> Yeah. Um, Last Shadow is what I think he
used to go by in the Starcraft world.
Um, but yeah, like there are people who
you go down a certain road
>> and it's really hard to course correct
at all.
>> It's No, it's a in my opinion, it's a
gilded cage. And what I mean by that is
you make cash, your cage is beautiful,
you know, it's it's lined with gold, but
you're stuck inside it. And and that's
where I do feel bad for LS uh that story
screamer streamer um and several other
center-right contrarian creators who
effectively in my opinion, they might
not even agree with me. Sure. But from
>> and I'm not implying there's a bunch of
people who are totally morally bankrupt,
selling out like don't believe it at
all, but just that like they might take
a slightly different direction. might
talk,
>> bro. I I like I just laugh. I don't
think I could be any more transparent in
my positions like on Twitter and it's
just like it throws me off that like I'm
just being very clear that like no issue
with chorus funding leftwing creators
and trying to create an ecosystem. My
more serious concerns with chorus have
been the seemingly coordinated response
to the article, right? And I list out
like the the actual problems I have,
none of which are even dark money. And
then I just get like told I'm agreeing
with the song. It feels it feels weird.
>> Anyway, talk about some things a little
bit less or a little bit more I'll try
to I'll try to complain less when I do
coffee.
>> I would they would be more spicy and
more independent if they knew that they
weren't going to lose 10 to 20% of their
audience as a result.
>> Yeah. So, yeah. So, this idea so I would
even challenge and a lot of what I've
just said I'm challenging a lot of
truisms. These are just supposed to be
things people take for granted like oh
having a single funer that's bad. You
should donate to creators directly.
That's the thing that people just they
think that's a good thing. That's kind
of
>> uh Pisco talk when? Um might be a chance
to talk to Bisco at some point. I could
like look at it, see if I could talk to
Bisco about it. The funny thing is is I
think I basically I think outside of
like some window dressing in terms of
what we actually think the solutions
are. I think Pisco and I align like 95%.
So it's funny that it seems like we
might disagree like massively. I don't
think that's the case
>> necessarily a good thing. And every
creator knows that the whole idea about
dark money being bad, is it bad? I don't
know if that's true. If somebody comes
up to me and they give me a bunch of
money, if my political opinions aren't
changing or anything, like I don't know
like would that matter?
>> Well, I mean that was my argument for
the for the PV because at the same time
like I never said, oh, Karma's amazing.
She's the best thing since sliced bread.
I said she's the lesser. She's the clear
lesser of two evils within this moral
calculus. And if you don't see that,
you're a idiot. Yeah. So that that is
actually not contradictory to anything
I've said for the past 5 or 10 years.
>> The thing that I think is important one
is the law is important in so far as um
like far should be respected. You can't
take like foreign money, right?
>> If you're representing those foreign
interests, you should disclose.
>> So I think like the laws I think in
place there are really important uh
number one. And then number two, I think
if people have highly sus or
questionable um like position changes,
then I think that that can be looked
into.
>> They need to be explained.
>> Yeah,
>> that that's my thing. So So for
instance,
>> but let's real quick like let's say I
found out tomorrow that let's say that I
found out that Hassan was taking a
million dollars a month fromQatar or
whatever. Well, they'd have to disclose
that. Let's assume it wasn't. You didn't
have to. It was it was legal to do that.
Let's say I found that out. I don't know
if that would change much of my
commentary at all on him because all of
the arguments are so it's all so stupid.
I would still fight basically the same
way. I might point out, oh wow, look at
you, you're getting a fat pocket for
doing this, but he also gets a pretty
penny from shilling for the prop pallet
crowd from his audience, right? So it's
like yeah, so there are a lot of truisms
that go along with like the dark money
thing that I would actually but this is
like a nobody's thought about these
arguments and they would be really
triggered hearing them the first time
around. So my uh
where I apply some degree of latitude is
explanations. So So for instance, like
if you change your perspective, let's
say, you know, I don't know, you're a
pro-Russian show one day and then switch
to Ukraine. Yeah.
>> But you explain how your
>> Sorry, I just saw Willie change his uh
his title.
>> The Destiny situation is unhinged.
Scorch Earth has now become Destiny's
unironically stupid. Lawyers, it's over.
Cool.
>> So, I just I noticed that change and I
wanted to point that out to you guys.
>> You're like,
>> let's keep going.
>> You know, my family grew up in Russia. I
bought into some of the Putin
propaganda. I read Alexander Dugan. I
thought he was brilliant. Um, but then I
actually started talking to my Ukrainian
family and they explained like
everything that they were going through
as a result of Russia and I realized
like actually, you know what, Ukraine is
in the right in this. Then I would be
like, "Oh, okay. Who gives a shit?"
Like, you change your mind, but you
change your mind off of articulable
evidence. Whereas if somebody flips on a
dime and they have no explanation, then
I'm like, "Oh,
either you're you realize that this is
where your audience was and you did not
want to alienate your audience or you're
taking cash from someone and you you
know, there has to be an explanatory
value for a ma massive shift or
contradiction in principle."
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And I'm able to articulate all of mine,
which is one of the things where I get
frustrated where people are like, "Hey,
you've changed all your principles." And
I'm like, "Name one."
>> Yeah. And then it's like and then yeah
like okay fine like are we going to be
in this world where like I want to see
all of your income sources then how does
Taylor Lawrence make all her money?
>> So why the should they know anything
else about anybody else right? Like why
should anybody know
>> that's your rabid capitalist coming out
though?
>> What do you mean? Well, where I think
that
uh media creators so so for instance
like if um Sagur and Jetty and Crystal
Ball
>> if they were taking loads of money from
Cotter I would want to know that because
they have like a pretty strong uh
uni party
uh Israel
>> Sagal Sagal
>> bad you know slant to their news while
they're
>> oh I just did the accent and I just
realized actually that I I need to go
over to uh r/ chase talk. There is
somebody who like listen I have some
some actual people in this audience uh
about the increased hate towards Indian
men. I should read this at some point on
stream. I do feel bad
I feel bad cuz I've got some people in
the community who are actually like nice
people who are Indian. I know that
sucks. It sucks. Anyway,
>> still pretending that they're
independent. And so if they were taking
$100 million from Carter or $10 million
from Cotter, I would want to know if
that was a substantive part of their
funding because I would realize that
they're catering to that bias.
>> Yeah, that's possible. Their arguments
would still be because they are they are
what they are. But like I just I
actually feel bad cuz I know a bunch of
uh Okay, off Cherry off. Uh I just feel
bad. I realize that it could be a troll.
Okay, I realize it could be a troll. I
just feel bad because uh I actually do
know some Indian people from like DG
generally. I've had like a lot of
co-workers who have been Indian Indian
Canadians and they've all been like
really good people. So,
>> but I'm just saying like but I'm just
saying that if we if we need to know
like chorus like the fact that these
people are funded by chorus and it's not
enough to know that they're funded by
chorus. We have to know that they're
funded by chorus um via the 1630 fund
but it's not enough to know that they're
funded by chorus via the 1630 fund. We
have to know who funds the 1630 fund.
And then I
>> I don't think anybody's making this
argument. Is Taylor Maybe Taylor's
making this argument. Maybe
um I don't make this argument. And I
have no problem with with people saying,
"Hey, I think it's really crazy."
Although, did did Taylor not say that
like I understand this a part of the
game?
Bro, it's like there's just so many
things here where it's like really
obvious that uh
like there's not a lot of push back from
people. I'm again I'm I'm going to say
that response to this is what has
actually kind of killed me more than
almost anything else. I guess who funds
the indiv because like again people are
so brainwashed on the dark money thing.
You'll read I reading the Taylor Lens
article. There was a part where she's
like um four mega donors gave however
much money to this blah blah blah blah
blah and they donated um mainly to back
it was like anti-abortion pro-choice. It
was pro No.
>> Yeah. What's the problem?
>> No no no. But it wasn't that. It was she
said like they donated to for pro-choice
causes. Um they donated for to fight for
this on the ballot over this and nobody
knows what their interests are. And it's
like [__]
>> those are the four interest.
>> Those are the interests. You just
>> Isn't Taylor's network paid by the 1630
fund? No. No. And they they took $45,000
in 2022. Taylor says it was a refund for
other services or something. I have no
idea that that's true. It's pretty
obvious that for what Taylor's doing
now, they are not taking money from the
1630 fund. The Omidia Network themselves
actually put out a statement saying,
"No, they're not taking money from the
1630 fund." This is just factually
incorrect. It's incorrect in every
possible way.
But people will just run with this lie.
People are continuing to run with this
lie. It's very sad. You
>> said it. Yeah. What are you talking
about?
>> But this is these are like very
different from the articles. Like you're
literally explaining it in the what
their interests are. Like what else? And
this is why I'm saying
>> another nefarious thing they're up.
>> Yeah. And I'm like what are we talking
about here? Dude,
>> I will say that I believe Pierro Midiar
must be one of the major contributors to
the 1630 fund and possibly even Chorus
because when Brian Tyler Cohen makes his
rebuttal to Taylor Loren, he doesn't say
that she's funded by dark money, he says
that Taylor Lens is funded by somebody
who also funds the 1630 fund, which is
just interesting to me.
>> This is why I'm saying the concept is so
stupid. They're like, "Well, you
>> Yes. So that's $40,000 Internet Ray that
they took in 2022.
You understand that, right? That that
LLC took $40,000 in 2022. And I believe
that LLC is somehow I think it is Oh,
let's look at the Omidar uh statement
again. So our programmatic our
programmatic work is supported entirely
via our foundation and LLC. So is this
the Omidar Network LLC?
It took $45,000. So it's not funded by
1630. Maybe you could argue that it
could be funded by dark money if that
was coming entirely out of the LLC. I
believe that the 1630, sorry, I believe
that Omidar has to report some of the
stuff already. I do wonder where the um
reporters and residents program, like if
you looked at all of that, right? I
wonder where that funding would come
from. LLC's don't disclose publicly.
Uh okay, LLC's don't disclose publicly.
Sure, possibly. But they do disclose,
right? As in that is tracked by like the
the IRS. I believe it has oversight.
Unless I'm missing something. Anyway, we
continue. Well, I don't
>> We can go back to chorus stuff at some
point in the near future.
>> Who the when people talk about dark
money, they mean public disclosure. I
think they mean infinite um infinite
money with no oversight is what they
mean, right? They pretty explicitly mean
501c4s
in my opinion. care like is there unless
the money is like drugged and you like
touch it and you're getting hypnotized
like what what is what are we talking
about here?
>> No, that's actually so funny because
that was the same thing with PB. So
they're like oh down ballot down ballot
they they want to get progressive
candidates and I'm like okay but that
wasn't my project. My project was the
canvasing operations for the man the
general election for Trump. So So and by
the way Jamal Bowman I think was the
only down ballot thing that PV did and
he got his dick kicked in.
>> So
>> okay. Yeah. Like,
>> so if we're going to play this game
where you have to see the funding from
some of these smaller creators, then
fine. Then all of you should start
posting tax returns. And if people want
to normalize that,
>> this is so brain damaged.
This is not actually a reasonable
argument. It's so stupid
>> in this world, man. [__] it. I'm fine
with that. We can normalize the out of
it. But whatever definition you're using
for dark money, Taylor Leurren
absolutely qualifies. Taking money from
that media, whatever the [__] group,
that is easily dark money under any
definition that she would use. So, if
we're going to use the dark the dark
money, then everybody and you can see I
haven't gone through all this yet, but
like the Young Turks raised a whole
bunch of [__]
>> everybody when everybody's talking about
dark money in politics, they're talking
about 501c4s that allow unlimited
contributions so long as they don't like
uh what do you call it like coordinate
with campaigns
>> money I think the Hill raised a whole
bunch of money from from some external
finance Glenn Greenwald raised like $7
million like all
>> dark money is like almost explicitly and
it's what Taylor's talking about the
501c4 things with like uh super PACs
like it's it's this exact thing.
>> All these people have relied on external
funding for all other media media
organizations. Not me by the way. But
I'm just saying that like if people are
if people want to do this then fine then
let's all post our 1040s. Like let's do
it if that's what you want to do. But
don't but but all of what I'm saying I'm
right now I'm playing the game by saying
that. Not playing the game. The reality
is Taylor the Rinse doesn't give a about
any of this. They just want to destroy
it. That's all they want to do.
>> Well, and that's what I was going to say
is like the the main takeaway that I
would want to articulate is that like I
too instinctively
believe that it's not ultimately about
disclosure because if if they disclosed
it then they would just move the bar.
Exactly. In my opinion,
>> where's getting fun? Where's 1630
getting fun? Who are these people? Yeah.
>> What what it's really about is it's
about creating the narrative.
I don't know why you have to self
victimize when I literally lay out the
exact things I want for this to be like
totally fine in my opinion. Why is the v
why is the victimization required?
>> Why why do we have to
are not political campaigns? I know um
neither are super PACs. Um
>> I don't know why they have to self
victimize like this. They're like, "Oh,
even if we even if we did exactly what
they said, they want more." No. I don't
I don't know why we have to pretend.
>> I uh maybe you know what there's maybe
they're just talking about Taylor
>> and reinforcing of the uni party that's
bought and uh bought and sold.
>> I don't know if I'm saying that
properly, but I'm tired.
>> But it's bought and paid for by the
donor class who holds it holds back the
interests of the left. Hold backs the
interests of the far left. And so as a
result, what they're trying to do is
they're trying to uh demoralize liberals
from defending liberals so they can get
a bigger
>> capture the party and coup the party.
That's what they want to do.
>> I think so.
>> Yeah. 100%. And they're not part of the
party. That's why I don't like the Oh,
you use that term crabs in a bucket.
They're not crabs in a bucket. They're
evil people invading the bucket. And
it's not a circular firing squad. It's
just a firing squad. Um these are just
people who are enemies to the party and
they they want to take over the party.
They should go make their own. Tell them
the [__] off.
>> Who's going to fire back?
>> We we have to. But this is why I'm
saying and again not to I love him.
Okay. Is I don't know but like for peace
or whatever, right? Remember one of the
groups we argued about before was the
Vanguard.
>> Yeah.
>> Those guys are standing huge on Taylor.
I'm sorry.
>> I feel like that tell the rent that's a
testing point. If you're a huge Taylor
sport on that article, that's great. Go
make your own party. Get the out of
Don't pretend you're a [__]
>> By the way, do do you know the exact
reason that is why it is, right? It's
because enough of Destiny's enemies
support Taylor Ren and are like, "Oh,
this is really weird to just lie about
her over this article and enough of the
people he likes support Chorus. It's
just very very easy calculus, right?
That's all that's happening."
>> Hold on. So, what's so funny about that
though is um the the Vanguard boys, and
I want them to hear this, okay?
>> Their creators I don't know if they have
like 100k subs or something,
>> but their big fish for who they are and
how recently they started creating.
>> Why does he say Vanguard's not crystal
ball? He would say crystal ball and
Kyle, I think. I think he would say get
them all out of here. But it's just like
it's just him. It's just boring. And
it's it's in my opinion why like nobody
nobody does take him seriously. They're
starting to realize that he's not
somebody you can take seriously as a
political actor in any way, right?
Because obviously
I think no matter what you'd have to
admit that a lot of people are lying
about Taylor Ruins.